la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
m'a demandé de présider cette séance de
question gouvernement elle se trouve
actuellement à Prague où elle participe
au 2è sommet parlementaire de la
plateforme de Crimée manifestant ainsi
le soutien que les démocraties apportent
à
l'Ukraine la parole l' ordre du jour
appelle les questions au Gouvernement et
la parole est à Madame Fatia keloa
Hachi merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche en 2017 le candidat en marche
à la présidence nous promettait la
construction de 60000 logements
étudiants et de ne plus avoir personne
qui dorment dans les rues sans surprise
cette promesse est non
tenue depuis 2017 c'est devenu
l'habitude les promesses non tenues et
les 493 qui s'enchaînne de semaine en
semaine et même si on ne s'attend à rien
on est quand même déçu
indigne voilà le mot qui me vient à
l'esprit quand je pense aux conditions
de vie et d'étude de nos jeunes indigne
quand h logements sur 100 sont vides et
que les étudiants dorment dans la rue ou
dans leur
voiture indigne quand le cru ne peut
proposer aux étudiants qu'un logement
sur 16 demandes en moyenne indigne quand
12 % des étudiants renoncent à leur
projet d'étude faute de
logement crise du logement baisse des
aPL hausse des prix de l'énergie servir
les plus riches pour déshabiller les
plus pauvres encore et
toujours
les étudiants ne veulent plus de vos
mesurettes madame la ministre ils
veulent s'émanciper vivre dignement et
de manière
autonome mais surtout ils attendent que
le gouvernement tienne enfin ses
promesses en assurant à chacun un
logement alors madame la ministre quel
dispositif d'urgence mettez-vous en
place pour ne laisser plus aucun
étudiant dormir dehors c'est une
question de dignité
bravo merci la parole est à Madame
Sylvie retaillot ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche merci merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur Madame merci madame
la Présidente messieurs madames les
députés madame la député Fatia kalouashi
d'abord je vous remercie pour la
question parce que ça me donne
l'occasion effectivement de dire ce que
ce gouvernement et cette majorité fait
pour les étudiants de façon générale et
en particulier dans le cadre du logement
et dans le contexte actuel le logement
étudiant effectivement actuellement
comme tous les logements aujourd'hui
connaît une crise je vous vois pas mais
et ce logement étudiant on avait un plan
de 60000 logements 30000 logements ont
été réalisés depuis 2017 aujourd'hui le
logement étudiant fait partie d'une
crise de foncier et nous sommes en train
d'identifier avec le ministre du
Logement le foncier disponible pour
pouvoir continuer cet engagement de
passer de 30000 logements déjà réalisés
au 60000 logements et puis c'est
travaillé dans de bonnes conditions pour
les étudiants vous l'avez dit et donc
dans ce cadre là c'est 12000 logements
sur les 175000 logements du cru qu'il
reste à rénover et nous avons déjà
planifié cette rénovation de ces 12000
logements 4000 sont en cours
actuellement et 8000 sont planifiés
jusqu'à 2027 et puis je vous rappelle
que nous avons gelé les loyers de Cruise
depuis 4 ans nous avons augmenté les APL
et que cette majorité a gelé aussi pour
les conditions étudiants les droits
d'inscription mais aussi beaucoup les
les toutes les les droits d'inscription
effectivement et les restaurations et
nous avons mis sur la table pour cette
rentrée un demi-milliard de plus sur la
vie étudiante en particulier sur cette
première étape des bourses c'est cette
majorité qui depuis 10 ans a fait le
plus sur la réforme des bourses et sur
l'augmentation des bourses étudiantes je
vous remercie merci Madame la Ministre
madame la
députée je retiendrai pour la je
retiendrai les 12ègues mes chers
collègues un tout petit peu de silence
madame la députée à la parole re je
retiendrai pour la 12000 les 12000
logements et la rénovation et j'espère
que ce sera pas uneè promesse non tenue
merci merci la parole est au président
Chenu merci Madame madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre madame la Première
ministre la semaine dernière dans notre
pays des manifestations se sont
déroulées jeudi dernier en particulier
sous les sinistres cris de Allah Akbar
sinistre cri à quelques mètres du
Bataclan quelques heures après quelques
jours après le décès l'assassinat de
Monsieur Dominique Bernard les Français
sont inquiets les Français sont choqués
avec les députés du rassemblement
national avec Marine Le Pen nous sommes
la voix de ces Français choqués inquiets
et exigeant vous avez pendant des années
criminalisé ceux qui ont lancé l'alerte
vous avez pendant des années voté des
subventions à des associations complices
pourtant il en a fallu du courage pour
nous pour des militants pour des
intellectuels pour dénoncer cette menace
islamiste dans notre pays il en a fallu
du courage pour s'opposer à votre dénis
pour s'opposer aujourd'hui à cette
gauche qui présente Israël comme un
régime d'apartide qui présente le Hamas
comme une armée légal il en a fallu du
courage pendant des années aujourd'hui
madame la Première ministre comme vous
le savez nous avons fait avec Marine Le
Pen un certain nombre de proposition de
loi pour s'opposer à l'islamisme et au
danger qu'il représente dans notre pays
allez-vous vous donner nous donner les
moyens juridique et législatif de
combattre cette idéologie de lutter
contre ces expressions politiques
intellectuelles culturelles
vestimentaire et son apologie à travers
les manifestations les écrits les
prêches ou bien allez-vous continuer à
interdire des manifestations qui se
déroulent quand
même
merci la parole est à Monsieur giralde
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
[Applaudissements]
outrers madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Chenu vous
aurez constater que le gouvernement de
la République a été extrêmement clair et
nous avons été les seuls en Europe à
faire nous avons interdit toutes les
manifestations pramas qui se sont tenu
dans les heures et dans les jours qui
ont
venu contrairement à ce qui s'est passé
à Berlin contrairement à ce qui s'est
passé à Londres contrairement à ce qui
s'est passé à Washington contrairement à
ce qui s'est passé en
2013-24 la police de la République les
préfets de la République ont pris leur
responsabilité en effet nous avons
constaté que la justice administrative
alors à moins que vous remettiez
totalement en cause autre État de droit
la justice administrative a autorisé
puisqu'elle a réformé la décision du
préfet de police la manifestation qui
s'est déroulé dimanche dernier cette
manifestation qui s'est roulé dimanche
dernier pour lequel nous respectons les
décisions de justice effectivement pour
la plupart des manifestants se sont
déroulés dans les premiers temps de
façon tout à fait convenable et puis sur
des slogans antisémite antisioniste
inacceptaable ignominieux qui n'ont pas
été condamnés malheureusement par les
partis politiques qui ont organisé cette
manifestation monsieur le
député il y a eu plus d'une vingtaine
d'interpellations des personnes qui pour
les services de Monsieur Gard desau
répondront au slogan sur les bébés
décapités qui n'existent pas ou
malheureusement des arguments
antisémistes absolument inacceptables la
consigne donnée à tous les préfets de la
République c'est d'interdire les
manifestations qui se dérouleront dans
l'ordre public qui peuvent effectivement
poser des questions oui pour soutenir la
cause palestinienne ou les civils
palestiniens mais lorsqu'on sait que des
collectifs comme Palestine vaincra dont
j'espère que le Conseil d'État donnera
raison au ministère de l'Intérieur pour
la dissolution les organise ce sera non
et nous porterons nous au ministère de
l'Intérieur à la justice tous les faits
qui sont contraire au droit merci
monsieur le ministre
monsieur monsieur le ministre force de
constater que votre loi sur le
séparatisme que vous nous aviez vendu
n'a strictement rien changé alors il
faut une législation particulière nous
la réclamons avec Marine Le Pen qui
nomme qui combat qui empêche
l'expression et même la la visibilité de
cette idéologie islamiste aujourd'hui
vous ne nous la présentez pas vous
refusez de combattre avec une
législation particulière la menace
islamiste n'attendez pas qu'il soit trop
tard
merci la parole est à Monsieur Jérémy
patrieletus merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre 60 ans plus tard je
suis toujours hanté par les images et
les odeurs des camps d'extermination de
la Choa jamais je n'aurais pensé que je
puisse faire mien chacun de ces mots de
Simone veille et pourtant je resterai
hanté à vie par ce petit matin du 7
octobre 2023 où pour quelques heures
l'humanité a déserté le monde je
resterai hanté par le visage de ces
enfants qui furent tués à bout portant
devant leurs parents je resterai hanté
par l'odeur insoutenable du camp de
Chura où j'ai vu les corps mutilés qui
disent la barbarie celle de cette mère
et de son bébé recroqueevillé et brûlé
vif madame la Première ministre si je me
permets d'évoquer sans pudeur l'atrocité
que j'ai vu en Israël avec mes collègues
c'est que je n'ai pas supporté les voix
qui se sont élevées dans notre pays pour
parler de CRIM de guerre les mêmes voix
qui s'en sont pris avec une brutalité
abjecte et la pire rhtorique antisémite
à la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
je veux lui dire qu'elle fait
l'honneur je veux lui dire faitneur de
cette assemblée madame la Première
ministre le président de la République
est en ce moment même en Israël pour
porter la voix de la France alors que
notre pays connaît la pire attaque
terroriste depuis des attentats de Nice
30 français ont été assassinés et neuf
sont portés disparus nous devons faire
bloc et chérir plus que jamais notre
unité c'est le le souhait des députés
horizon et de tous les républicains
madame la Première ministre je mesure la
gravité des mots que je vais prononcer
l'unité de la France la protection de
notre République la préservation de
notre démocratie sont en danger les
assauts viennent de toutes parts des
terroristes qui souhaitent détruire nos
valeurs celles des Lumières en
commençant par les enseignants les Juifs
encore et toujours des irresponsables
politiques qui ont fait de la
brutalisation du débat public de la
conflictualisation permanente de la
terreur des mots un fond de commerce
électoral macabre et funesse de seuls et
ceux enfin qui se complaisent à ne pas
voir que la lutte contre le terrorisme
et la préservation de notre unité sont
en définitive un seul et même combat
Premier ministre comment le gouvernement
de la France peut préserver notre
communauté nationale contre ceux qui
veulent la détruire la parole est à
Monsieur géralde Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des
[Applaudissements]
outres monsieur le madame la Présidente
pardon mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député la France compte la
première communauté juive d'Europe la
troè communauté juive du monde la France
protège tous ses citoyens et elle s'est
enrichie par l'histoire malheureusement
que s'en prendre au français de
confessions juives c'est s'en prendre à
tous les Français à toute la République
et je vais vous dire Monsieur le
Député que les Français de confession
juive le samedi à la synagogue prient
pour la République prie pour les
policiers pour les gendarmes et pour les
militaires et aujourd'hui les policiers
les gendarmes les militaires sont fiers
de protéger 900 lieux en France où ils
vont librement vivre leur culte amener
leurs enfants dans les écoles
confessionnelles s'ils le souhaitent se
balader effectivement dans n'importe
quel coin du territoire qu' s'agisse des
quartiers de la blieu parisienne ou de
la province française parce que les
policiers et les gendarmes protègent
jour et nuit ils sont plus de 10000
monsieurs les députés les Français de
confession juivees ce qui explique
malgré la grande peur et nous pouvons
les comprendre qu'il n'y a pas eu comme
dans d'autres pays européens des
synagogues attaqué avec des cocktails
molotop qu'il y a eu aujourd'hui plus de
400 interpellations de personnes qui ont
fait des actes antisémites et qui sont
présentés à la justice que nous le
retirons pour ceux qui sont étrangers
systématiquement le titre de séjour nous
les mettons directement au centre de
rétention administratif parce que être
responsable d'un acte antisémite porter
une menace antisémite porter ce que nous
avons trop vu y compris dans le débat
médiatique un relativisme antisémite
alors oui s'est porté atteinte à toute
la République et c'est contraire à leurs
valeurs à tous les Juifs de France je
veux dire que leur peur est la nôtre et
la protection de la République sera pour
eux sera pour leur lieux communautaire
et en France personne ne les aura les
toucher sans la foudre de l'État merci
Monsieur le Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur ééri
Caron merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues madame la Première ministre
le 7 octobre dernier le Hamas s'est
rendu coupable de CRIM ignobl contre des
civils israéliens plus de 1400 personnes
nont des enfants ont été tués dans des
circonstances qui suscitent l'effroid
l'indignation le dégoût au crime de
guerre du Hamas répondent aujourd'hui
les crimes de guerre de l'armée
israélienne selon les sources
palestiniennes les bombardements sur
Gaza ont déjà fait près de 6000 Mor en
grande majorité des civil parmi
lesquel00 enfants
pourant po de mesure dans l'indignation
dans cette assemblée des voix manquent
encore pour dénoncer le sort subi en ce
moment même par les
palestinien comme si une vie
palestinienne valait moins qu'une vie
israélienne plus grave encore la
présidente de cette assemblée 4e
personnage de l'État a voulu réitérer
l'expression de son soutien
inconditionnel au gouvernement israélien
en se rendant sur place accompagné de
plusieurs députés soutien de benjamine
netanahou lors de son déplacement la
présidente de notre Assemblée a déclaré
qu'il faut Ceres préserver les civiles à
Gaza mais que rien ne doit empêcher
Israël de se défendre ce qui revient à
donner un blancin à l'armée
israélienne aujourd'hui la France doit
demanderement répondra seul Emon a la
parole aujourd'hui la France doit
demander un cess le feu imédio doit
également dénoncer la colonisation et
demander son arrêt c'est le seul moyen
de continuer à croire en la solution à
deux état madame la Première ministre il
nous semblait madame la Première
ministre il nous semè déclaration d'hier
que c'est le chemin que la France
commençait enfin à choisir mais tout à
l'heure depuis Israël le président de la
République n'a pas prononcé ses mots il
a en revanche proposer que la coalition
contre l'État islamique puisse lutter
aussi contre le Hamas quelles sont les
implications concrètes de ces
déclarations pour la France est-ce que
ça veut dire madame la Première ministre
que la France renonce à exiger un cesser
le feu est-ce que ça veut dire que vous
renoncez à exiger le respect des droits
des Palestiniens merci monsieur le
député la parole parole est à Monsieur
Olivier ministre délégué chargé du
Commerce extérieur de l'attractivité et
des Français de
l'étranger merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Caron depuis
17 jours la France insoumise montre son
vrai visage celui de l'indignité celui
de l'indignité de pouvoir nommer ce qui
est véritablement le Hamas c'est-à-dire
un mouvement terroriste aucune cause
monsieur le député Caron aucune cause
ne jtifie que l'on assassine que l'on
décapite que l'on brûle des hommes des
femmes des enfants et des bébés c'est ça
la réalité ce que le président Loula ce
que le Conseil de sécurité au Brésil
nomme le Hamas en tant que mouvement
terroriste vous n'êtes pas capable de le
faire vous
ici ce que la la position de la France
la position de la France Monsieur le
Député est très claire elle a été
rappelée par le Président de la
République elle a été rappelée par la
première ministre a été rappelée par le
par la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères qui est aujourd'hui
encore au Conseil de sécurité à l'ONU
nous demandons aujourd'hui une trêve
humanitaire qui permettent d'acheminer
l'aide humanitaire que la France finance
également à hauteur de 20 millions
d'euros pour les Palestiniens nous avons
appelé nous avons appelé à ce que cette
rêve humanitaire amener à un cesser le
feu nous n'avons jamais fait
l'assimilation entre le Hamas et le
peuple palestinien et le président de la
République se rend en ce moment à ramala
nous défendons la solution à deux États
qui est la seule solution qui permettent
à deux peuples de vivre côte à côte et
en paix la position de la France elle
est claire contrairement à la vôtre
merci la parole est à
Madame
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame agè panorunaché
ministre de la transition
énergétique nos concitoyens nos
industriels nos entreprises ont
lourdement été éprouvé par la flambée
des prix de l'électricité en
2022 face à cette crise le gouvernement
et la majorité ont été au rendez-vous
pour protéger les Français comme nul par
ailleurs en Europe grâce à la mise en
place du bouclier tarifaire cependant
l'incompréhension persiste vis-à-vis des
prix de l'électricité qui apparaissent
en déconnexion avec ceux de notre
production il ne s'agit évidemment pas
ici de remettre en cause la solidarité
européenne au travers de notre marché de
l'électricité comme le propose le
rassemblement national avec démagogie et
irresponsabilité sans cette solidarité
nous n'aurions pas tenu face à la crise
il s'agit de défendre des prix sur le
long terme qui nous permettent de
modérer les factures des ménages et des
entreprises en limitant le lien entre
les prix de l'électricité et ceux du gaz
dans ce contexte la France a été à
l'avant-garde de ce combat en défendant
une réforme du marché européen et de
l'électricité c'est aujourd'hui un
succès que nous pouvons saluer cela a
permis de faire comprendre à nos voisins
allemands que la compétitivité de notre
entreprise nucléaire était un avantage
pour l'ensemble des européens la France
a supporté une parole forte et fédérée
autour d'elle un certain nombre de pays
au sein d'une alliance du nuclére pour
défendre l'intérêt des
consommateurs cet accord op est donc une
victoire française nous pouvons être
fier c'est aussi une victoire européenne
car nous renforçons notre compétitivité
vis-à-vis des États-Unis c'est enfin est
surtout une victoire pour le climat car
cet accord facilitera les
investissements dans la production
d'énergie décarboné pouvez-vous madame
la ministre nous indiquer quels seront
les prochaines étape de négociation et
ce que peuvent espérer les Français pour
leur facture d'électricité je vous en
remercie merci la parole est à Madame
agè panier runach ministre de la
transition
énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
luqué avec cet accord sur le marché de
l'électricité la France obtient une
victoire majeure comme vous l'avez très
bien souligné c'est une victoire de
l'Europe qui affirme sa puissance
économique face à la concurrence de la
Chine et à l'inflation reduction Act
américain c'est une victoire pour la
France et pour les Français avec un
traitement identique entre le nucléaire
et les énergies renouvelables c'est
aussi une victoire pour le climat car
les investissements dans les énergies
décarboné seront facilités une victoire
enfin celle du bon sens et celle de la
raison je vousadresse à vous celle du
bon sens et celle de la raison face à
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche qui
n'ont cessé de prener le repli sur soi
et la sortie du marché européen car à
quoi aurait mené le projet que vous avez
proposé la semaine dernière messieurs de
l'extrême droite dans votre proposition
largement décrié sur l'ensemble de ces
bans à augmenter massivement la facture
d'électricité des Français à mettre en
grave difficulté les industriels et à
porter atteinte à notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement au contraire avec
cet accord nous déconnectons les prix du
gaz et l'électricité c'était une
promesse nous la tenons nous empêchons
l'envolet des prix de l'électricité dans
les crises nous stabilisons les prix de
l'électricité sur le long terme pour les
industriels et pour les Français nous
sécurisons notre approvisionnement voilà
en d'autres termes comme l'a dit le
président de la République nous
reprenons le contrôle sur le prix de
l'électricité cet accord il est le fruit
de la vision de l'exigence que porte le
président de la République pour l'Union
européenne le travail que j'ai mené avec
l'Alliance Européenne pour le
nucléaire et également avec la
Commission européenne à payer cet état
est maintenant franchie nous allons
conclure en trilogue avec le Parlement
européen et nous tiendrons la prés la
promesse
président la parole est à Madame
Christelle pétex
Levet merci à madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Industrie monsieur le
ministre nos entreprises françaises sont
en danger et vous êtes si peu inquiet la
situation au savoyard est pour sûr le
reflet de ce qu'il se passe partout
ailleurs dans le pays
des entreprises volontaires et pourtant
à bout anxieuses de l'avenir dicté par
des contraintes étatiques qui
s'accumulent tout d'abord l'énergie la
fin annoncée de l'amortisseur
électricité pour les entreprises déjà en
difficultés comment faire face à des
factures exorbitantes et le monde entier
sait que la France a des tarifs
d'énergie des plus élevés les
industriels perdent déjà tous leurs
clients au profit de la concurrence
étrangère ensuite la prévention de la
gestion des déchets avec les fameuses
REP leur mise en place est très
inquiétante pour les entreprises
notamment du secteur du bâtiment du
recyclage ou encore du bois inflation
des taux des contribution inégalité de
traitement ou encore distorsion de
concurrence avec les produits importés
ce dispositif à l'instar de contribuer à
remplir les objectifs de décarbonation
et d'instaurer des conditions loyales
pour le marché se révèle être pénalisant
et
inéquitable autre exemple le zéro
artificialisation net l'agrandissement
des sites de production des entreprises
en bonne santé va devenir un véritable
casse-tête comment peuvent-elles faire
face à la concurrence internationale
répondre à la demande si on ne leur
permet pas d'adapter leur outil et
surface de production autant de
nouveautés qui se révèlent dans les fait
dé limitateurs du développement de notre
économie et déroule le tapis rouge aux
importations monsieur le ministre vous
rendez-vous compte que vous vous
acharnez
contre nos entreprises quand allez-vous
prendre conscience de l'ampleur de la
situation et leur prouver que nous
sommes bien à leur côté merci Madame la
député la parole est à r les ministre
délégé chargé de
l'Industrie merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés madame la
député si j'ai bien un
acharnement c'est de m'assurer que
l'industrie française va sortir gagnante
de toutes les crises auqu FA et des
opportunités qui se
présentent et ce combat madame la
députée le jour où le Président de la
République a promulgué le projet de loi
industrie verte qui a fait l'objet d'un
très large consensus de ces ban je suis
heureux de voir que la plupart des
députés sont prêts aussi à mener ce
combat à nos côtés vous avez mentionné
la crise énergétique la France a protégé
ses industries comme personne au monde
et j'étais aujourd'hui à la journée de
l'industrie automobile au Carroussel
d'ouive tout le monde y a reconnu que
l'industrie automobile a été résiliente
dans cette crise et c'est grâce à nous
vous avez mentionné les filières REP
vous avez mentionné l'objectif majeur
qui est de développer de l'industrie
circulaire pour oui en France être
capable de concilier industrie et
écologie nous étions avec le ministre de
la transition écologique vendredi pour
fêter les 70 ans de la cocotte minute à
dans la banlieu de Dijon l'industrie
française elle est prête à épouser cette
grande cause de la réparabilité de la
durabilité et de l'industrie et de
l'écologie madame la députée
rassemblons-nous autour de ce bon combat
nous sommes capables de réindustrialiser
la France nous sommes capables de le
faire en la verdissant nous sommes
capables de mettre la France et l'Europe
au sommet de la hiérarchie mondiale
rejoignez-nous soutenez-nous ensemble
soutenons les industries française et
faisons de l'industrie française un
gagnant merci merci madame la députée
merci Monsieur le Ministre j'en suis
convaincu maintenant agissons en
conséquence la parole est à Madame
Alexandra
Martin merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Gabriel
Attal ministre de l'éducation nationale
et de la jeunesse au professeur
enseignant instituteur directeur d'école
et à l'ensemble du personnel éducatif je
tiens ici à vous témoigner de toute ma
solidarité dans notre histoire
personnelle il existera toujours un
professeur qui nous a marqué le cœur et
l'esprit qui nous a donné l'envie de
nous élever de nous dépasser nous sommes
nombreux à nous souvenir et à partager
ces anecdotes des années collège et
lycées j'ai une pensée particulière pour
ma professeur de français Madame
Bernadet qui m'a transmis l'amour de la
littérature et le goût de l'effort l'un
comme l'autre ne m'ont jamais quitté
l'école est un lieu d'apprentissage
d'autonomie et donc
d'émancipation l'école est un lieu où
l'on peut se construire indépendamment
de toute influence extérieure comme
disait Jean joures dans sa lettre aux
instituteurs et institutrices c'est le
lieu où on peut être mis en état par une
éducation rationnelle et libre de juger
peu à peu toutes les croyances et de
dominer toutes les impressions premières
cette liberté aujourd'hui est menacée
chaque jour des professeurs craignent
d'aller enseigner chaque jour des élèves
angoissent en silence sur le chemin de
l'école chaque jour des s'inquiète le
climat dans lequel est plongée notre
école n'est plus acceptable la peur doit
changer de camp nous avons vu les
premières réponses face à l'urgence avec
le déclenchement du plan attentat mais
ce besoin de sécurité est plus profond
et exige une réponse durable notre école
doit revenir doit redevenir un lieu de
paix et de sérénité pour y parvenir nous
devons travailler avec tous les acteurs
concernés ainsi Monsieur le Ministre
comment le gouvernement compte-t-il en
associant les collectivités
territoriales répondre à ce besoin
urgent de sécurité je vous remercie
merci madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel hatal ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Alexandra Martin je veux vous
remercier pour les mots que vous avez eu
pour l'école et pour nos enseignants
vous remercier aussi pour la phrase de
Jean jores que vous avez cité et j'y
répondrai avec une phrase de Jean
qui disait que l'école doit rester
l'asile inviolable où les querelles des
hommes ne pénètrent pas cette phrase
elle dit tout elle dit tout le besoin de
sérénité que nous avons à l'école il n'y
a pas de sérénité sans
sécurité nos enseignants nos élèves les
familles ont besoin d'être rassurés sur
leur sécurité quand ils se rendent à
l'école on dit souvent ici que l'école
est un sanctuaire ou qu'elle doit être
un sanctuaire ça veut dire qu'on doit
toujours être plus en sécurité dans les
école qu'en dehors de l'école vous
l'avez dit les collectivités locales
sont en charge des bâtiments scolaires
et de la sécurité de ces bâtiment j'ai
réuni toutes les associations d'élu le
18 octobre dernier nous avons publié une
déclaration commune à l'issue de cette
réunion je le dis puisque c'est assez
rare pour être souligné nous avons état
et l'ensemble des associations d'élus
publié ensemble une déclaration commune
qu'est-ce que nous avons dit d'abord que
beaucoup d'investissements ont été
réalisés notamment depuis 2015 pour
renforcer la sécurité de nos
établissements scolaires mais qu'il faut
évidemment continuer à aller plus loin
j'ai déclenché une enquête flash sur
tous les établissements scolaires pour
mesurer le niveau actuel de sécurité les
résultats consolidés me seront transmis
dans les prochaines heures nous nous
reverrons dans les prochains jours avec
l'ensemble des associations d'élus pour
s'accorder sur les mesures essentielles
pour continuer à aller plus loin dans le
renforcement de la sécurité je le dis la
règle est claire on ne doit pas pouvoir
pénétrer dans un établissement scolaire
quand on a rien à y faire et si jamais
c'est le cas où qu'il y a une tentative
il faut que les personnels soi formé
pour y réagir et que les forces de
sécurité reçoivent l'alerte
immédiatement pour intervenir à partir
de là charge à chaque collectivité avec
le soutien de l'État de garantir que
nous y parvenons depuis 2017 nous avons
consacré 100 millions d'euros de l'État
pour accompagner les collectivité et
nous continuerons merci Monsieur min la
parole est à Monsieur
frédri merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre de la
santésieur ministre re de l'hôpital
public il y a normalement le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale mais si personne n dupe il n'y
aura pas de débat nous savons tous que
la première ministre est sur le point de
mépriser à nouveau les Français avec un
14e 493 vous n'écoutez pas non plus des
personnels soignants je vais donc me
faire leur porte voie ici en 2017 le
rapport du Sénat alerta sur les
conséquences des fermetures de lit
pourtant le gouvernement a continué à
enfermer la santé c'est du régalien
sanctu le budget de l'hôpital public à
un niveau conséquent ce ne sont pas mes
mots mais ceux d'un médecin urgentiste
de l'hôpital de sainemuse de la
pénutropole toulonaise le personnel
soignant le personnel en maladie n'est
pas remplacé on accumule les semaines de
60 he avec les fermetures des services
d'urgence aur dans levar nous subissons
une haose d'activité sans renfort les
services d'urgence de Brignol va perdre
de médecins s'il ferme alors ça craquera
nous n'y arriverons pas des patients
restent jusqu'à 10 jours dans les
urgences par manque de lit si notre
crise devait advenir nous serions
incapablebl d'y faire face ce ne sont
pas mes mots mais ceux des membres du
collectif de sain mususe que j'ai
rencontré samedi dernier ils sont à bout
de souffle le 13 octobre quasiment la
totalité du personnel étent en arrêt
maladie ils sont épuisés physiquement et
moralement le service d'urgence de
sainteem est le refet de ce qui se passe
partout en France si l'hôpital va mal
les services d'urgence sont à l'agonie
alors Monsieur le Ministre quand allez
mettre vous les moyens humains et
financiers pour sauver l'hôpital public
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame ages
firmain lebudau ministre délégué chargé
de l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député
bcalti vous m'interrogez sur la
situation des urgences et sur la
situation de tension que nous
connaissons particulièrement dans leev
dans leev nous avons connu un été
particulièrement difficile pour pour le
système dans santé j'ai dit
particulièrement dans leev et je tiens
ici une nouvelle fois à souligner
l'engagement de l'ensemble de tous les
professionnels de santé le travail de
Laars avec les élus locaux a d'ailleurs
permis de mieux anticiper les
difficultés il faut le souligner la
situation la plus délicate est sans
doute cette des urgences de Toulon où un
mouvement spontané comme vous l'avez
souligné a conduit de nombreux
professionnels de santé à se mettre en
arrêt de travail de nombreuses
consultations ont été conduites et le
dialogue a été renoué je tiens à le
saluer et à saluer leur engagement cela
a permis une reprise de l'activité avec
Aurélien Rousseau nous sommes très
attentifs aux conclusions de la
concertation qui sera mené par les
professionnels de santé mais ces
situations de lvard ne sont pas isolé
vous le savez et je tiens à rappeler à
quel point le travail de fond que nous
avons engagé sur l'hôpital et en
particulier sur les urgences est
essentiel oui les difficultés sont
réelles et oui les urgences ne sont que
le symptôme de problème bien plus
profonds c'est pourquoi la question des
ur a fait l'objet de décisions très
importantes depuis juillet 2022 un
soutien au personnel travaillant dans
les services des organisations innovante
travailler avec les acteurs de nouvelles
complémentarités entre les
professionnels de santé notre
préoccupation c'est bien le bon
fonctionnement de la filière urgence de
laamont à laav on le sait les urgences
ne fonctionne que bien lorsque le par le
parcours des patients est fluide
généraliser le sas les services d'accès
aux soins c'est laamont mieux organiser
les flux et enens ensuite bien sûr
rouvrir des lits en aval nous rouvrirons
des lits que s'il y a des professionnels
de Sanger qui travaillent vous le voyez
monsieur le député les services de
l'État et le gouvernement sont
pleinement mobilisés sur ces sujets
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
député excusez-moi mais vos propos ne
sont pas du tout convainquants et ne
sont pas au niveau de ce qu'attendent
les soignants en même temps cela n'est
pas étonnant puisque le ministre de la
Santé est un ancien directeur de Laars
l'hôpital public est au fond du trou et
vous continuez à creuser encore et
encore à la prochaine crise le système
écoulera et vous porterez l'entière
responsabilité du drame sanitaire qui
s'annonce alors réveillez-vous l'hôpital
public est merci la parole est à
Monsieur Perseval
gaillard merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outres mèes à la
Réunion se communes sur 24 sont soumises
à des restrictions d'eau dont la commune
de Saint-Leu dans ma circonscription
alors que l'été australe débute à peine
h autres sont placés en vigilance des
usages de l'eau dont Saint-Paul TR
bassins les avirons lestanalet et
Saint-Louis le mois dernier je suis allé
à la rencontre des habitants du chemin
paillett à la Chaloupe Saint-Leu qui
sont privés d'eau potable depuis 40 ans
200 personnes qui survivent avec l'eau
croupie des retenues cinaires et
quelques bouteilles d'eau qui leur sont
acheminé femmes enfants et personnes
âgées compris comment cela est-il
possible en 2023 77 ans après la
départementalisation de la réunion sur
ce dossier j'ai interpellé la préfecture
qui doit réunir bientôt l'ensemble des
acteurs autour d'une Mme table nous
espérons avoir le soutien de l'État pour
trouver une solution rapide à ce
problème qui dure depuis bien trop
longtemps depuis bien trop longtemps
partout dans nos territoires
transocéanique la question de l'eau se
pose de manière aigu faisant suite à des
années de sous-investissement structurel
en Guadeloupe la situation est
catastrophique à maotte elle est même
pire maintenant qu'avant la
départementalisation lorsque notre
collègue de l'anupes Madame Rousseau
vous a interrogé sur Mayotte vous n'avez
pas pu vous empêcher de faire le lien
entre vot votre obsession l'immigration
et la crise de l'eau monsieur le
ministre nos peuples méritent mieux que
d'être les otages de jeux politiciens
nationaux la question de l'accès à l'eau
est une question fondamentale qui ne
fera que se poser avec plus d'acuité
dans les prochaines années il faut
choisir entre le champagne pour
quelques-uns et l'eau potable pour tous
disait Thomas Sankara pendant que
certains s'enrichissent sans honte
d'autres n'ont même pas accès à l'eau
voilà la réalité de notre pays en 2023
êtes-vous prêt à prendre l'engagement
ici devant la représentation nationale
de mettre en place dans les plus brefs
délais les grandes assises de l'eau dans
les territoires d' d'outrem débouchant
sur un plan d'investissement massif dans
nos infrastructures merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur
géraldarnin ministre de l'Intérieur et
des
[Applaudissements]
outremes madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés vous avez parfaitement raison
dans les utresèes et singulièrement dans
l'océan Indien il y a des difficultés
fortes d'accès à l'eau depuis très
longtemps sous l'effet du réchauffement
climatique du manque de nappe fréatique
mais aussi mais aussi il faut bien dire
du phénomène nign qui touche
particulièrement le sendindien et
Mayotte et en ce qui concerne les choses
à la Guadeloupe à Mayotte ou à la
Réunion vous neavez pas dit dans votre
intervention vous il faut aussi
souligner que ce sont des
responsabilités des collectivités
locales et s'il y a sousinvestissement
je veux dire ici que ce n'est pas de la
part de l'État si votre question si
votre question est que l'État reprenne
la main sur un certain nombre de
dispositifs locaux nous y sommes prêts
comme on l'a proposé aux élus de Mayotte
et comme on l'a proposé jalice avec le
ministre le Cornu en Guadeloupe où 320
millions d'euros sont désormais investis
où la question de l'eau n'est pas
totalement réglée mais en partie en
train d'être réglée par le travail très
important d'investissement de l'État oui
vous avez raison organisons ces assises
de l'eau le ministre des outres mèes ira
très prochainement à la Réunion pour
justement sur la thématique de l'eau
vous rencontrez les acteurs locaux
proposer en effet fait que le préfet
puisse reprendre la main sur une partie
des compétences si les collectivités le
souhaitent pour payer en effet
l'ingénierie qui manque et notamment
vous le savez bien dans les fuites qui
sont nombreux dans les réseaux d'eau et
bien évidemment pour pouvoir faire que
tous les citoyens de notre pays quel que
soit leur territoire et singulièrement
bien sûr dans les territoires qui ont
été déportmentalisés puissent avoir de
l'eau potable de l'eau courante et vous
avez parfaitement raison ceci n'est pas
encore le cas aujourd'hui donnons aux
collectivités locales les moyens de le
faire par l'investissement mais aussi
par la compétence directe de l'État
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
député il me reste 2 secondes monsieur
monsieur le ministre après les paroles
on attend les actes maintenant
merci la parole est à monsieur
Jean-Jacques
Gautier merci présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
Culture et concerne les missions et le
financement de l'audiovisuel public qui
représente plus de 4 milliards par an
pour les français et qui nécessite donc
transparence évaluation contrôle
l'audiovisuel public a un rôle central
pour notre démocratie face aux
désinformations pour notre culture face
aux plateformes américaines pour notre
économie en matière de droit d'auteur ou
de fiction française par exemple mais il
faut réaffirmer plus clairement ces
différences avec les chaînes privées
différence en matière de mission l'arcom
a rendu récemment un avis assez critique
jugeant insuffisante l'offre de culture
sur France 2 et France 3 les chaînes
avec les plus fortes audiences est-il
normal d'ailleurs que l'audience de
France 4 ne soit plus mesurée et il est
important que vous puissiez contrôler
l'exercice de ces missions de service
public différence de financement
également puisque en matière de
financement dans un marché publicitaire
global qui baisse ou qui stagne qui se
dép porte vers le numérique les recettes
publicitaires de France Télévision ont
augmenté de 2018 à 2022 ce qui est une
exception en en Europe puisque'en
Angleterre en Allemagne et en Espagne
dans les pays scandinaves il n'y a pas
de publicité sur l'audiovisuel
publicique c'est aussi une sorte de
détournement de l'esprit de la loi de
2009 qui supprimait la publicité après
20h alors madame la ministre comment
comptez-vous contrôler la publicité sur
le service public et est-ce que le
gouver ouvernement est favorable à la
proposition de loi organique
transpartisane visant à pérenniser le
financement de l'audiovisuel public
après
2024 merci monsieur le député la parole
est à Madame RA abdoumak ministre de la
Culture merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Gautier merci de
votre engagement sur ce sujet important
qui est l'audiovisuel publique et sa
place dans notre paysage notamment dans
une période de lutte contre contre les
désinformations pour travailler sur
cette trajectoire pluriannuelle qui est
sur 5 ans qui est proposé aujourd'hui
aux entreprise jusqu'à 2028 et sur les
contrats d'objectifs et de moyens nous
nous sommes appuyés en grande partie sur
les propositions que vous avez formulé
avec Quentin bataillon lors de votre
mission d'information donc je pense
qu'on partage les constats que vous avez
soulevés les constats soulevé par
l'arcom sur un vieillissement de
l'audience et un besoin d'être plus fort
sur la stratégie numérique NOTAM
le besoin de préserver la place de la
création de l'accès à la culture mais
aussi le rôle d'éducation au médias de
de ces chaînes de ces programme et
l'enjeu de proximité l'importance de
cette information locale d'un média de
la vie locale d'où l'enjeu d'accélérer
sur les rapprochements entre France 3 et
France Bleue tous ces débats nous les
avons eu à plusieurs reprises c'est ce
qui va se traduire aujourd'hui dans les
contrats d'objectifs et de moyens avec
des missions donc de service public
réaffirmé précisé avec un un contrat
d'objectif et moyens encore plus
stratégique plus précis et une nouveauté
dans la trajectoire financière que nous
présentons qui est d'avoir une dotation
de base pour les pour les entreprises
comme précédemment mais aussi une
enveloppe complémentaire qui sera
actionnée au fur à mesure de
l'accélération des transformations de la
modernisation des projets prioritaires
et qui sera réservé sur 3 années 2024 25
26 pour justement aller plus vite sur
ces coopérations et ces enjeux
prioritaire que vous mentionnez on a
bien en tête la même ambition un ausel
public moderne fort qui respecte le
pluralisme la fiabilité de l'information
qui lutte contre la désinformation et
qui touche plus la jeunesse voilà merci
monsieur le député je je souhaite en
tout cas que le gouvernement fasse
preuve de la même réactivité que le
Parlement puisque le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale ont travaillé
ensemble et de matière transpartisane
merci
pour la parole est à Madame Jacqueline
Maquet merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre du Logement le logement
essentiel à la dignité humaine se trouve
au centre des préoccupations de nos
concitoyens et constitue un pilier
fondamental de notre société le logement
représente non seulement un cadre de vie
et un enjeu pour le pouvoir d'achat et
l'emploi il est également un levier
indispensable de notre transition
écologique situation actuelle du
logement en France est très
préoccupante nous sommes confrontés à
une crise marquée par des difficultés
structurelles tel que la diminution du
foncier disponible la baisse des permis
de construire exacerbé par une crise
conjoncturelle lié à la hausse rapide
des taux d'intérêt des efforts ont été
déployés à travers le Conseil national
de la refondation pour augmenter l'offre
soutenir les plus modestes et mettre en
place une stratégie de rénovation
énergétique à grand échel
ces efforts ont mis en lumière la
nécessité d'une stratégie collective
mobilisant l'ensemble des des acteurs du
secteur les mesures annoncées telles que
l'assouplissement de l'accès au pré
immobilier le développement du locatif
intermédiaire la refondte de la
fiscalité locative le renforcement de la
garantie visale sont des pas dans la
bonne direction mais largement
insuffisant largement insuffisant dans
ce contexte monsieur le ministre
pourriez-vous nous préciser votre vision
votre stratégie pour accélérer la
production de logement en France comment
surmonter les défis structurels et
conjoncturels comment équilibrer les
équilibres d'accessibilité de durabilité
et de dignité comment mobiliser et
coordonner les efforts des collectivités
des promoteurs des bailleurs des
aménageurs pour concrétiser cette vision
et répondre de manière efficace et
pérenne aux besoins présents en matière
de
logement mer madame la députée la parole
est à Monsieur Patrice
vergriet ministre délégué chargé du
logement madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les les députés madame la
députée Jacqueline Maquet oui nous
vivons actuellement une crise de la
production du logement avec une baisse
d'un tiers des permis de construire
d'ici la fin de l'année cette crise
s'explique en grande partie par la forte
hausse des taux d'intérêt dans un
contexte de rareté foncière comme vous
l'avez évoqué le gouvernement y répond
avec détermination de deux manières
d'abord à travers une série de mesures à
caractère économique pour aider nos
concitoyens et pour rééquilibrer les
opérations de construction de logement
c'est le sens du renforcement et de
l'élargissement du prêt at zéro
particulièrement incitatif en ce moment
c'est le sens du soutien au logement
locatif intermédiaire c'est le sens des
mesures en faveur du logement loca
social qui a donné lieu à un accord à
Nantes au Congrès HLM c'est le sens
également des abattements sur les
plusvalues de session foncières pour
donner des terrains à nos opérateurs
au-delà de ces mesures le Gouvernement
engagera également des actions plus
fortte et plus ciblé sur les territoires
qui en ont le plus besoin j'ai eu
l'occasion de l'évoquer la semaine
passée le lancement du programme
territoire engagé pour le logement
auquel tient particulièrement le
président de la République
ce programme vise à accélérer la
production de logement dans la vingtaine
d'agglomération où la pénurie est la
plus forte aujourd'hui à travers des
mesures financières mais aussi
réglementaires nous avons réussi à
accélérer la production de logement pour
les Jeux Olympiques de Paris nous
pouvons le réussir également pour
répondre à la crise de la production du
logement du surmesure donc et au regard
des retours des des premiers courriers
que je reçois des élus locaux je puis
vous dire que ce surmesure plaît
particulièrement collectivité locale et
qui donne lieu un programme
particulièrement intéressant vous le
voyez donc le gouvernement répond avec
détermination à la crise de production
du logement je vous remerci ministre la
parole est à Monsieur jean-pa
LEC merci madame la Présidente chers
cègues depuis l'agression terroriste du
Hamas en Israël et plutôt que de réagir
par le droit et la justice le
gouvernement israélien se déchaîne
contre la population palestinienne le
blocus total de Gaza et les
bombardements ont déjà tué des milliers
d'innocents en s-jordanie et à Jérusalem
est occupé la colonisation continue plus
de 90 Palestiniens y ont été tués par
des colons et par l'armée israélienne en
2 semaines plus de 600 israéliens arabes
ont été expulsés de chez eux en guise de
représaill et des campements de réfugiés
sont assiégés par l'armée israélienne
c'est indigne d' démocratie
pourriez-vous me dire il faut le
rappeler le peuple palestinien n'est pas
responsable des horreurs du Hamas alors
que le conflit déborde dans les pays
arabes voisins la France la France
membre du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies doit poser en urgence des
actes forts pour que nous trouvions plus
vite le chemin de la paix le corridor et
les moyens humanitaires ne sont qu'une
goutte d'eau pour la population la
France doit agir pour obtenir au plus
vite un cesser le feu permettant
notamment la libération des otages cela
entame
cela entamera une nouvelle de
négociation de paix en tenant compte des
leçons de l'histoire ce cesser le feu ne
peut conduire à un statut C il doit
conduire à un accord de paix les
pacifistes israéliens Palestiniens ou
français le réclam depuis des années et
propos de très nombreuses solutions à
mettre en œuvre rapidement les paroles
des bellcistes n'ont fait qu'ampirer le
drame malheureusement seul les morts
font réagir en 2014 notre Assemblée a
voté une résolution visant la
reconnaissance par la France de l'État
palestinien près de 10 ans plus tard il
est temps il est temps d'y accéder le
président de la République semble enfin
y être prêt si la France posait un acte
diplomatique de cette ampleur quel
message quel message magnifique et utile
pour la paix êtes-vous prêt à urer
concrètement la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier ministre délégué chargé du
Commerce extérieur de l'rac
[Applaudissements]
l'éanger merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député
Lecoq pardon si la ministre de l'Europe
et les affaires étrangères est absente
et je prie
d'excuser c'est justement parce qu'elle
est au Conseil de sécurité des Nations
unies parce qu'elle est au Conseil de
sécurité et que nous
défendons Conseil de sécurité depuis
plus de une
semaine la question de la trêve
humanitaire qui doit déboucher sur un
cesser le feu à
terme la France a condamné avec la plus
grande fermeté les attaques terroristes
du Hamas nous avons soutenu le droit
d'Israël à se défendre et à répliquer de
manière légitime dans le respect du
droit Inter national dans le respect du
droit de la guerre et dans le respect du
droit
humanitaire nous sommes au
soutien du peuple palestinien à travers
l'aide humanitaire 20 millions d'euros
ont déjà été engagés et s'il faut
rallonger ce montant nous le ferons nous
y sommes prêts en ce qui concerne la
position de la France elle est claire
monsieur le député et elle est claire
depuis 30 ans nous avons
soutenu depuis les accords d'Oslo la
solution à deux États qui permettent au
peuple palestinien et au peuple
israélien de vivre en paix côte à côte
la position de la France la position de
la France est claire et elle n'a pas
varié et c'est ce que le président de la
République a rappelé à la fois
aujourd'hui à telavive à jésusazem et à
ramala merci merci Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas Dupont
teignan merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre mardi dernier nous étions tous
rassemblés avec émotion pour rendre
hommage à Dominique Bernard victime du
terrorisme islamique j'ai bien écouté la
réponse de la première ministre et je
n'ai noté malheureusement que deux
annonces concrètes le réhaussement du
plan Vigipirate et le recyclage du
projet
immigration rien
sur le rétablissement des frontières
nationales seul moyen d'empêcher
l'infiltration de nouveaux terroristes
rien non plus dans vos propos sur une
refonte complète de l'examen du droit
d'asile dans des centres fermés au
frontières pour éviter que les déboutés
restent sur notre sol rien non plus dans
vos propos sur un référendum pour
revenir à la primauté du droit national
sur le Maqui des jurisprudences et des
directives de l'Union européenne qui
paralysent et vous le savez tous notre
état rien non plus dans vos propos sur
la suppression des aides et des visas
pour les pays qui empêchent l'exécution
des octtf seulement 6,9 % des octtf
exécutés en
2022 rien sur sur la fin de votre
politique folle de rapatriment des
femmes djihadistes de Syrie il y en a a
80 dans nos prisons qui sortiront
bientôt alors ma question est très
simple après 273 victimes du terrorisme
dans notre pays quand allons-nous passer
quand allez-vous passer des discours
creux des gesticulations au
rétablissement de notre souveraineté
nationale pour protéger nos concitoyens
et vaincre cette guerre insidieuse qui
nous menace merci Monsieur député la
parole est à Monsieur Géral ministre de
érieur et des autres Mair ah pardon
monsieur le garde des saau monsieur éc
duupontéti merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député du
ponteignan gesticulation
dites-vous qui a créé le parquet
national
antiterroriste où étiez-vous qui a
renforcé le renseignement péniten
pénitentiaire où étiez-vous qui a créé
les quartiers d'évaluation de la
radicalisation où étiez-vous monsieur
monsieur le député qui a créé les
quartiers les quartiers de
déradicalisation où étiez-vous qui a
voté la loi séparatisme où étiez-vous
monsieur le député qui a renforcé le
nombre de policiers de magistrats dans
ce pays où étiez-vous vous étiez trop
occupé en réalité avec vos camarades
Bigard et les autres à nous dire que le
vaccin tua nos compatriotes
vous ne représentez que vous-même et où
êtes-vous pour dire que nous avons évité
43 attentats et où êtes-vous pour dire
que la justice antiterroriste a
parfaitement fonctionné dans ce pays
vous arrivez vous surfez sur les morts
comme vous avez surfé sur les malades
voilà Monsieur D
ponignan monsieur le député
monsieur Dupont Moretti votre réponse
est une insulte aux millions de Français
qui se font du souci pour leur
sécsieurputé la parole est à Madame
Christine
[Applaudissements]
harigi merci madame la Présidente cette
question de 2 minutes le temps de la
démocratie du mardi s'adresse à Clément
bonne ministre des Transports alors
Monsieur hatal puisque vous êtes présent
je pousse un cri d'alerte parce que
depuis la réforme blancaire la France ne
sa'est plus compté non non je vous
adresse à vous monsieur hatal ça me dit
entre 9000 et 10000 manifestants dans le
Tarne Clément bonne en annonce 2400 Sam
me dit en marge de ces rassemblements
une cinquantaine de personnes masquées
s'en prennent à une entreprise action
heureusement circonscrite par les forces
de l'ordre que l'on remercie monsieur le
ministre en annonceela des milliers
alors évidemment je pousse un cri
également d'interpellation madame
rotillot le gouvernement tourne
délibérément le dos à la communauté
scientifique qui ne cesse d'alerter sur
les effets de l'inaction climatique et
se fait déloger dimanche à coup de gaz
lacrimau lors d'un débat déclaré en
préfecture dans un champ privé prêté par
un agriculteur or que vaut une
démocratie qui relativise les savoirs
scientifiques nous alerta hier dans une
tribune Guillaume Carbou pendant ce
temps l'État a choisi de confier la
concession autoroutière à la société
atosca détenue à 60 par deux deux
sociétés capital risque de droit
luxembourgeois sommes-nous d'accord
monsieur le ministre sur ce pourcentage
de 60 % pendant ce temps l'État a
consenti un contrat de 55 ans avec la
société Tosca sommes-nous d'accord
monsieur le ministre que ce contrat a
bien été signé pour 55 ans et
pourriez-vous nous dire pourquoi une si
longue durée pourriez-vous également
nous confirmer qu'alon des formules
mathématiques figurant dans le contrat
hormis les véhicules électriques dont on
ne sait ni comment ni par quelle
technologie ils seront repérés le tarif
entre castre et verfeille pour 53 km ne
serait déjà plus de 6,80 € soit 6,77 €
arrondi au terme du contrat à 6,80 €
mais de 7,90 € auquel il faut rajouter à
ce jour 1,70 pour arriver jusqu'à
Toulouse par là 68 soit allerretour
19,20 € soit 100 € par semaine 86
exactementame député la parole est à
monsieur Clément ministre délégué chargé
des
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
transports madame la Présidente mesames
et Messieurs les Députés madame la
députée harigi tout à votre complottisme
et à votre humour noir je regrette que
vous n'ayez pas commencé par le
commencement madame hargi que vous
n'ayez pas commencé madame hargi par les
principes républicains les plus
élémentaires que vous n'ayez pas
commencé par condamner les violences
inacceptables qui ont eu lieu et ça
n'est pas une question d'arithmétique à
part celle et le le chiffre est
malheureusement élevé des SEP gendarmes
qui ont été blessés par des violences
scandaleuses madame la députée hargi je
regrette que vous n'ayez pas commencé
par saluer l'action des agents de l'État
du préfet du Tarne des forces de police
sous l'autorité du minist de l'Intérieur
qu'il faut respecter l'ordre républicain
je regrette madame Harig que vous n'z
pas eu un mot pour les fonctionnaires de
l'État pas un mot pour appeler le
nécessaire respect du droit de
manifester dans le cadre de la
République et de l'ordre nécessaire
madame la députée
ce n'est pas une question d'arithmétique
c'est une question de démocratie je
regrette que N pas eu un mot pour
condamner et vous cautionner de faites
ces violences parce que madameigi quel
que soit le nombre exact quel que soit
le nombre exact il y a eu des centaines
et même des milliers d'individus
radicalisés qui ont incendié vrai ou pas
vrai madame harg qui ont incendié deux
bâtiments qui ont empêché les pompiers
d'éteindre l'incendie madame har qui ont
porté parce que Madame Rousseau a porté
très long loin l'indescence en défendant
le port de canif avec des couteaux avec
des pioches qui ont voulu être violent
alors madameg vous avez le droit d'être
contre un projet nous en avons discuté
longuement vous avez le droit
d'encourager et de participer à des
manifestations vous n'avez pas le droit
d'oublier le respect des principes
républicains les plus élémentaires quant
à la discussion elle a toujours été
ouverte vous avez passé des heures en
discuter avec moi vous le savez mais il
faut d'abord respecter les principes
nécessaires de notre démocratie et notre
état
merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole
madame je ne crois pas il vous reste pas
de temps de
parole vous n'z plus temps de parole non
non
non il ne reste plus de temps de parole
à Madame c'était le temps de parole de
Monsieur le Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Alain
David merci madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre au moment où vous
avez déclenché le premier d'une longue
série de
493 au moment où vous créez par
amendement un paradis fiscal pour la
FIFA en rejetant simultanément des
amendements adoptés en commission
l'austérité dans laquelle vous vous vous
enfermez continue à produire ses effets
dévastateurs vous ne prévoyez rien ni
pour les anciens ni pour les jeunes sur
lesquels je vais me
concentrer dans ma circonscription et
partout en France on constate que les
jeunes qu'ils soient étudiants apprentis
jeunes salariés glissent de plus en plus
sous le seuil de pauvreté la h cette
précarité les affecte dans tous les
penses de leur vie leur logement mais
aussi leur alimentation leur santé
comment peuvent-ils dès lors poursuivre
sereinement leurs études pour les uns
l'apprentissage d'un métier pour les
autres ou leur insertion dans le monde
du travail comment se projeter dans la
vie quand on toi que la galère pour ne
pas dire la misère une tribune publiée
dans le journal Le Monde revendiquer il
y a peu un revenu universel auquel le
président a malheureusement violemment
fermé la porte le groupe socialiste
quant à lui a fait des propositions pour
lutter contre l'inflation qui touche
durement les plus jeunes et vous
persistez à les balayer d'un revers de
manche madame la Première ministre
l'urgence sociale est grande et de
nombreuses familles en appel aux
associations d'entraide ou aux
collectivités locales l'État ne peut
plus être absent face à cette précarité
grandissante vos choix budgétaires ne
peuvent pas continuer à favoriser
outrageusement les Plantis des mesures
d'urgence doivent rapidement être prises
à la mesure de la détresse de la
jeunesse merci merci monsieur le
député allez-y madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le député David à force de
crier dans cet hémicycle vous oubliez
peut-être ce qui s'y est passé mais si
aujourd'hui je suis assise en bas de ces
bancs j'étais pendant un an à côté de
vous au-dessus et je peux vous dire
qu'il est quand même assez savoureux
d'entendre qu'encore aujourd'hui vous
niez l'effort qui est fait par cette
majorité par ce gouvernement depuis 2017
plutôt que d'essayer d'écouter prenez
peut-être des notes nous avons favorisé
l'apprentissage nous avons favorisé
l'emploi des jeunes comme jamais nous
avons permis aujourd'hui avec le
ministre Olivier du sopt de signer le
500000e contrat d'engagement jeune
500000 jeunes ont été accompagné dans
l'insertion vous parliez aussi des
jeunes étudiants qui a permis de mettre
la création du repas à 1 € c'est nous
qui a pérénisé ce système pour les plus
précaires et les les boursiers c'est
nous qui a les les loyers des crouses et
les et les exactement c'est nous merci
encore une fois être assis à gauche de
l'hémicycle c'est peut-être bien
enemporter les valeurs c'est
mieux merci monsieur le
député monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
député madame la ministre j'ai bien noté
que tout allit bien finalement et que
tous ceux qui sont dans la pauvreté
merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Antoine
Armand merci merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Madame Agnès
panier runaché ministre de la transition
énergétique madame la ministre le 17
octobre dernier vous avez obtenu un
accord historique au Conseil européen
sur la réforme du marché européen de
l'électricité nous nous le savons tous
ici les règles du marché définis ces
dernières années elles pénalisaient la
France et au-delà elle pénalisait tout
notre continent dans la transition
énergétique et nous étions nombreux sur
ces bancs sur tous les bancs à en
déander une réforme profonde une réforme
et pas une sortie pas un frexit à la
fois absurde et dangereux parce que oui
nous avons besoin d'électricité à chaque
instant nous avons besoin de l'échanger
avec nos voisins et nous en avons besoin
pour notre sécurité d'approvisionnement
c'est ça la souveraineté
nationale nous l'avons nous l'avions
fait de manière transpartisane dans la
commission d'enquête parlementaire dont
j'ai eu l'honneur d'être le rapporteur
nous l'avons porté en emble c'est vous
madame la ministre qui avez porté cette
réforme et grâce à vous non le nucléaire
ne sera plus un paria à Bruxelles merci
et
bravo merci la par vous ah pardon je
croyais merci madame la Présidente vous
avez obtenu cet accord grâce à
l'alliance des pays du nucléaire que
vous avez su initier que vous avez fait
vivre quel contraste madame la ministre
quel contraste avec les démagogies de
certains dans cet hémicycle qui étaient
tous en retard on avait on avait les
créatif au partis socialiste et leurs
alliés de la nupes ceux qui voulaient
nationaliser une entreprise qui était
déjà détenue à 100 % par l'État bravo et
puis nous avions les grands réactifs au
rassemblement national tellement
réactifs qu'il voulaient supprimer un
dispositif larine dont on dispose dont
on négociait déjà la sortie et le
successeur bravo ce qui compte ce qui
compte madame la ministre c'est d'avoir
maintenant la loi de production annoncée
par le président de la République et je
vous demande donc quelles sont les
prochaines échéances queles sont ces
orientation nous sommes nombreux sur ces
bancs à être prêt à la soutenir dans un
esprit transpartisan et non politicien
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame Agnès
panier runacher ministre de la
transition
énergétique et oui je travaille monsieur
le député merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Armand permettez-moi
avant de vous répondre de paraphraser le
président de la République
tout le monde nous disait que c'était
impossible et pourtant nous l'avons fait
parce qu'il ne connaissait pas la France
il ne connaissait pas l'Europe et
surtout il ne connaissait pas la
détermination de cette
majorité à réformer notre système du
marché de l'électricité à reprendre
notre destin énergétique en main merci
pour ça à cette majorité il ne
connaissait pas notre détermination à
obtenir de la Commission européenne et
de notre voisin allemand un accord soit
favorable aux Français et favorable aux
Européens cette détermination pour bâtir
notre souveraineté et notre
compétitivité et surtout pour répondre
au défis de ce siècle sortir des
énergies fossiles pour mieux lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique car
nous avons tenu nos promesses nous avons
déconnecté le prix de l'électricité du
prix du gaz nous avons obtenu la
reconnaissance du nucléaire et nous
reprenons le contrôle des prix
l'électricité
cet accord il marque donc un tournant
pour la France il renforce la position
de la France en Europe il est le
résultat d'efforts acharné et
effectivement il n pas été simple à
obtenir il est le résultat du
volontarisme du président de la
République et de l'ensemble des équipes
qui l'ont négocié c'est la meilleure
réponse à la concurrence chinoise et à
l'inflation reduction Act américain
c'est la meilleure réponse à l'extrême
droite et à l'extrême gauche qui n'
cessé de prener le repli sur soi avec la
sortie du marché européen maintenant que
cet accord est en place nous nous
tournons vers l'avenir avec la loi de
production énergétique auquel vous avez
contribué avec des groupes de travail
qui ont réuni l'ensemble des groupes de
cet hémicycle constructif nous allons
donc avancer avec ces lois qui permettra
de
baisser la parole est à Madame Florence
boulet
merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la transition
énergétique mardi 17 octobre dernier un
accord a été conclu entre les États de
l'Union européenne sur la réforme du
marché de l'électricité et le
gouvernement se félicite d'une victoire
française pourtant il n'y a pas lieu de
se réjouir car les factures énergétiques
des ménages et des entreprise ne
baisseront pas cet accord témoigne une
fois de plus du ren du gouvernement à
défendre les intérêts de la France et
des
Français dans notre pays nous sommes
passés en quelques années d'une vision
d'avant-garde portée par le général de
Gaulle puis georgees Pompidou un choix
idéologique catastrophique souscouvert
d'un mythique couple franco-allemand qui
n'existe que dans les couloirs de Bery
le prix de l'électricité française reste
indexé sur les le Prix européen du du
gaz et les prix dérogatoires ne
concernent pas les ménages ni la grande
majorité des entreprises la France va
rester privée de la compétitivité que
lui offre son parc nucléaire et
hydraulique
existant les pris énergétique à moyen et
long terme vont donc continuer
d'augmenter d'autant plus que vous
supprimez progressivement le bouclier
tarifaire la compétitivité du nucléaire
à travers les CFD ne bénéficiera qu'
producteur d'énergie pour développer des
unités d'énergie décarboné comme
l'éolien et le
photovoltaïque autrement dit rien ne
change votre gouvernement nous laisse
donc pied et point lié au dogme européen
de la concurrence le tout restant sous
le contrôle de la Commission
européenne madame la madame la ministre
pourquoi ne voulez-vous pas comme nous
le réclamons nous libérer des règles
absurdes du marché européen de l'énergie
et remplacer le système actuel des prix
par un prix français de
l'électricitéame la député la parole est
à Madame agè Pier runach ministre de la
transition énergétique merci madame la
Présidente Messieurs et Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Goulet quand l'Europe gagne c'est les
Français qui gagnent et c'est le
rassemblement national qui recule vous
vouliez sortir du marché européen et au
fond sortir de l'Europe tout court nous
vousos la solidarité européenne celle
qui a garanti notre approvisionnement en
électricité l'hiver dernier là où vous
préfériez mettre les Français dans le
noir vous avez fait du marché européen
de l'électricité le réceptacle de votre
détestation de l'Europe au mépris de la
sécurité d'prisionnement énergétique de
notre pays de la facture de des Français
au mépris de nos industriels au mépris
même de DF nous vous opposons un accord
historique qui est une victoire pour
l'Europe pour la France pour le
nucléaire pour le climat et surtout une
victoire pour les Français et vous avez
jeté toutes vos forces dans la bataille
pour nous faire croire que l'Europe
était responsable de la crise
énergétique mais madame la députée nous
vous renvoyons au vrai responsable vos
amis russes qui ont envahi l'Ukraine
Marine Le Pen n'a cessé de porter une
position de repli mortifère pour notre
pays que même vos amis hongrois et
italiens ne suivent pas avec la
président de la République avec la
majorité dont je salue le travail nous
vous opposons ce succès diplomatique qui
est le fruit d'une politique
volontariste européenne car qu'on fait
Marine Le Pen et le rassemblement
national pour défendre les Français rien
avez-vous voté les boucliers énergétiqu
qui ont permis de protéger massivement
les Français non vous avez rejeté chacun
des dispositifs de protection des
Français permettant de leur faire
bénéficier des prix parmi les plus bas
d'Europe vous avez même une proposition
de loi insensée qui aurait conduit à
l'augmentation brutale des Pruit pendant
que votre parti prospre sur les
difficultés des Français nous leur
apportons des réponses concrètes pendant
que vous voyez petit nous voyons
ministre merci
merci la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe nelen merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé notre système est en crise et
notamment dans les territoires ruraux
l'hôpital de Remirmont en est le parfait
exemple malgré le manque de moyens le
manque de personnel toutes les équipes
de ce centre hospitalier que je connais
bien sont extrêmement mobilisé et engagé
auprès de leurs patients à la suite de
récent incident la crise que traverse
cet hôpital s'est encore intensifiée si
l'on peut regretter l'acharnement d'une
avocate plus intéressé par la pub que
par la quête de justice ou encore le
traitement médiatique de certaines
émission télévision obsédé par l'udimat
au détriment du débat contradictoire et
constructif monsieur le ministre c'est
bien d'un manque de moyens dont nos
hôpitaux publics souffrent il faut
recruter plus de personnel il faut aussi
plus soutenir et plus considérer le
personnel soignant en place ils sont les
premiers maillons de la chaîne de soins
et les plus à même de faire remonter les
problématiques de terrain que
comptez-vous faire pour venir en soin à
C
qui dans sa globalité est largement
éprouvé par tout ce qui se passe
actuellement Monsieur le Député la
parole est à Madame firm
lebudau ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député nagenel oui
comme j'ai eu déjà l'occasion de le dire
plusieurs foisélien Rousseau oui les
difficultés à l'hôpital sont bien
réelles et oui nous sommes
quiddiellement mobilisé pour y apporter
des réponses afin de garantir la qualité
et la sécurité des soins notre
préoccupation est bien de fidéliser les
professionnels de santé et de redonner
de l'attractivité au métiers du soin que
ce soit en terme de rémunération je vous
rappelle le segéure de la santé mais
j'ai aussi les annonces de la première
ministre il y a quelques semaines pour
valoriser le travail de nuit pour les
professionnels non médicaux à hauteur de
1,1 milliards mais aussi en terme de
conditions de travail et l'objectif
numéro 1 c'est bien de de rouvrir des
lits d'assurer en faveur du
développement continu des professions
médicales et paramédicales que ce soit
par la formation ou le développement
d'action qualité vous m'interrogez sur
spécifiquement l'hôpital de Remirmont
nous suivons en lien avec les services
de l'État cette situation compliquée de
très près et vous avez eu raison de la
souligner à la suite de différentes
plaintes de familles de patients ces
derniers mois plusieurs inspections de
la RS se sont tenus les rapports
d'inspection et les mesures correctives
envisagées ont été partagé à l'étable
établissement en septembre dernier il
soulligne des problèmes d'organisation
interne j'ajoute que les difficultés
très récentes et les événements graves
de ces derniers jours au sein de
l'établissement ont suscité par mesure
de précaution la suspension de
l'activité de chirurgie non programmée
il y a des mesures correctives
immédiates dont la mise en œuvre
pourrait permettre une reprise des
activités chirurgicales dans quelques
jours de manière sécurisée pour les
patients tous les acteurs les
professionnels sont mobilisés pour se
faire en outre un plan d'action est
élaboré son déploiement sera suivi par
l'ARS en parallèle une attention
particulière est portée aux équipes et à
la nécessité de restaurer un climat de
confiance la direction de
l'établissement et de la RS travaille
aussi à des propositions en ce sens vous
le voyez monsieur le Président les
services de l'État sont pleinement
mobilisés pour le CH de Remirmont merci
monsieur le
député merci Madame la la présidente
au-delà des réponses qui ont été données
j'appelle réellement votre attention
sur la mentalité et l'état dans lequel
se trouve le centre hospitalier romarie
Montin et j'invite monsieur le ministre
de la Santé à se rendre sur place à
venir à Remirmont on a besoin d'un
message fort de notre ministre comme
quoi il y a un avenir pour l'hôpital
public dans les territoires ruraux et
comme quoi il y a un avenir pour
l'hôpital public de
Remirmont merci monsieur le député avant
de passer la parole à Monsieur germigon
je voudrais indiquer que lors de la
prise de parole de Monsieur Jean-Paul
leco le mot assassin a été prononcé sans
doute par Madame Parmentier puisque ça a
été inscrit par les services du
compte-rendu que ce mot n'a pas la place
dans notre hémicycle et que donc j'en
avertirai le bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale qui mènera une investigation
plus
précise monsieurigon vous avez la
parole merci Madame merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse au
ministère du logement au ministre du
Logement monsieur le ministre il y a 2
ans le gouvernement annonçait la mise en
place de ma prime adapte ce dispositif
important vise à soutenir nos
concitoyens de plus de 70 ans en offrant
un accompagnement et une aide financière
au ménage destiné à adapter leur
logement face à la perte
d'autonomie ce dispositif alors que
10000 seigneurs meent chaque année des
suites de d'une mauvaise chute s'inscrit
dans une démarche résolument tournée
vers le bien-être et la sécurité de nos
années qui souhaite à une écraisante
majorité vieillir chez eux l'une des
caractéristiques phares de cette prime
réside dans l'association d'une
expertise professionnelle à la mise en
œuvre des adaptations en effet il a été
évoqué l'intervention d'un
ergothérapeute et d'une assistance à
maîtrise d'ouvrage pour établir un
diagnostic précis et personnalisé du
logement garantissant ainsi que les
travaux entrepris soient en phase avec
les besoins réels du
bénéficière de plus l'importance
d'impliquer des entreprises habilitées
par les organisations professionnelle du
bâtiment a été souligné assurant qualité
et conformité dans les
réalisations ce dispositif s'inscrit
parfaitement dans la lignée des
engagements pris par le gouvernement
pour renforcer notre politique en faveur
du grand âge bien que nous ayons encore
du chemin à parcourir pour bâtir notre
modèle du Bien Vieillir de demain
notamment ce qui concerne le maintien à
domicile cette prime adapte constitue
une pièce maîtresse de cette vision dont
la question du logement fait partie
intégrante après consultation des
services de l'Agence nationale de
l'habitat ainsi que de la direction
départementale des territoires il m'a
été rapporté un manque de directive
clair transmise à ces organismes nous
sommes à présent à 2 mois de l'entrée en
vigueur de cette mesure et une telle
situation soulève de légitimes
interrogations monsieur le ministre
j'aimerais savoir où en êtes-vous dans
la mise en place opérationnelle de ce
dispositif quelles sont les instructions
données aux différents services merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Patrice vergriet ministre
délégué chargé du
logement madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député
Gernigon d'abord vous avez parfaitement
raison notre pays vit une transition
démographique extrêmement forte en 2050
c'est environ un tiers des Français qui
aura plus de 60 ans et seulement 6 % du
parc de logement a été adapté constate
encore 10000 chutes mortelles chaque
année ce qui est effectivement largement
à à améliorer vous en
consentirez c'est la raison pour
laquelle madame la Première ministre a
annoncé et souhaité la création de
maprimadame ce dispose ce fond d'aide au
au travaux d'adaptation au 1er janvier
2024 ce fond d'aide sera géré par
l'Agence nationale de l'habitat que vous
avez cité doté d'un montant de 250
millions pour l'année 2024 il sera
distribué au plus de 70 ans et même plus
de 60 ans en cas de perte d'autonomie
précoce les aides pourront aller jusqu'à
70 % du montant des travaux pour les
bénages les plus modestes et nous
envisageons l'adaptation d'environ
700000 logements dans les 10 ans à venir
le dispositif sera également ouvert aux
personnes en situation de handicap les
instructions ont largement été donné
mais j'aurai l'occasion de refaire le
point avec les services de la NA puisque
vous m a invité mais je veux également
vous dire qu'avec ma collègue Aurore
berger nous aurons l'occasion de revenir
sur ce dispositif qui a fait l'objet
d'une large concertation conoconstruite
avec les associations de la solidarité
et de l'ensemble des associations du
grand âge pour vous donner l'ensemble
des détails relatif à ce dispositif
merci à vous merci la parole est à
Madame Murielle
levron merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre l'heure n'a jamais été aussi
grave pour nos éepades en début d'année
déjà une enquête de la Fédération
hospitalière de France alertait sur la
situation à la fin de l'exercice 2022 85
% des épats public était déficitaire les
primes grand âge et séur de la santé
accordé aux salariés étaient plus
qu'attendu mais comment expliquez-vous
qu'elle ne soit pas entièrement financé
par l'État et qu'elle pèse sur les
finances des établissements sans compter
que cela s'ajoute à la hausse des prix
de l'énergie et des produits
alimentaires liés à l'inflation ça n'est
plus tenable les directeurs et
directrices des pades sont face à un
dilemme suspendre le paiement des
factures au risque de se voir priver de
chauffage ou d'électricité cet hiver ou
utiliser le personnel comme variable
d'ajustement au risque de priver les
résidents d'un accompagnement adapté et
on commence à avoir des épades fermé
c'est le cas à laanobre en mars dernier
et plus récemment à Brest pour deux
établissements qu'ad vient-il des
résidents du personnel des familles
aujourd'hui des citoyens s'organisent
afin de combler l'inaction de l'État
c'est le cas à Plou arê sur ma
circonscription des habitants vendent
des crêpes sur le marché pour pour aider
financièrement les pad alors que c'est à
vous d'agir et en même temps les
scandales ne cessent d'éclater dans les
groupes privés lucratif après Orpa et
coriant le groupe A est à son tour
accusé de pratique de maltraitance notre
groupe parlementaire de la France
insoumise a d'ailleurs déposé une
proposition de loi créant une
responsabilité pour faute de l'État en
cas de maltraitance institutionnelle
dans les épades avec davantage de
contrôle le scandalea aurait pu être
évité et des maires en avec les épates
sont approché par ces grands groupes
favoriser la course au profit sur leur
gris révèle le cynisme de votre
politique de santé loin de tout esprit
de solidarité le pls que vous allez nous
imposer par 493 n'est pas à la hauteur
et quant à la loi bienveillir nous
attendons les débats qu'il s'imposent
madame la ministre face à l'urgence de
la situation que comptez-vous faire pas
dans les mois ou années qui viennent non
je vous demande ce que vous comptez
faire maintenant merci Madame la député
la parole est à Madame Aurore Berg
ministre des solidarités et des
familles merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée c'est pas juste ce qu'on va
faire maintenant c'est ce qu'on fait
depuis 2017 ce qu'on fait depuis 2017 en
matière d'autonomie c'est la création
d'une 5è branche une 5e branche dont
vous avez voté en 2020 la création avec
vous le savez une code part de CSG qui
est attribué et qui permet de le
financer à hauteur de 2,6 milliards
d'euros oui il y a eu des
revalorisations des revalorisations de
900000 personnels en éepad de tous les
personnels des EPAD des revalorisations
aussi d'ailleurs dans l'ensemble des ESS
pour les personnels soignants en tout
c'est 3,5 milliards d'euros d'engagement
de l'État pour garantir la
revalorisation de ces personnels oui il
y a eu aussi un tarif un bouclier
énergétique qui a été mis en place avec
une compensation de l'inflation de 200
millions d'euros en 2023 et cette
compensation de l'inflation elle va
continuer sur les enjeux énergétiques en
2024 donc l'engagement de l'État il est
très clair il est très clair à la fois
en trajectoire de financement il est
très clair en matière de revalorisation
des personnels parce que tout ce que
vous dites madame la députée part
d'abord des professionnels et je pense
que vous auriez pu saisir votre question
pour d'abord remercier celles et ceux
qui s'engagent au quotidien auprès des
personnes âgées auprès des personnes en
perte d'autonomie que ce soit les aides
à domicile que ce soit les personnels
des épades parce qu'en vérité c'est sur
eux et souvent sur elle d'ailleurs que
repose l'effort c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans ce PLFSS 2024 nous
inscrivons bien la trajectoire de
garantie de 50000 personnels
supplémentaires d'ici 2030 avec 6000
postes mais oui mais la vérité vous le
savez quand vous êtes un peu moins
démagogique c'est que vous savez bien
que pour arriver à la création de ces
postes il faut non seulement créer de
l'attractivité il faut rémunérer mieux
il faut recréer de la vocation si vous
voulez matin midi et soir dire à quel
point la situation est désastreuse alors
que ça n'est pas ce qui se passe alors
forcément vous n'arriverez pas à
recruter si vous dites au contraire ce
qui se passe en éepad sur la dignité des
personnes sur l'accompagnement des
personnes sur le soutien qui est fait
aux personnes alors vous recréez de
l'attractivité vous recréez de l'envie
et en plus nous on met l'argent sur la
pour permettre ses revalorisation merci
Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Madame Stéphanie Rist bonjour madame
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous
débutons cet après-midi l'examen du
budget de la Sécurité sociale pour 2024
ce budget c'est 643 milliards d'euros
un/ers de notre richesse nationale pour
protéger nos concitoyens ce budget doit
s'inscrire dans une trajectoire de
maîtrise de notre déficit public tout en
poursuivant l' ement et la
transformation de notre système de santé
c'est un budget engagé engagé dans la
prévention avec le financement des
campagnes de vaccination contre le
papillom virirus contre la gratuité des
préservatifs pour les moins de 26 ans
par exemple engager dans l'amélioration
de l'accès aux soins avec
l'élargissement de l'accès à la
complémentaire santé solidaire la
possibilité donné aux pharmaciens de
délivrer des antibiotiques après test
diagnosti pour les angines et infections
urinaires ou encore la transformation du
financement des hôpitaux qui permettra
de mieux financer nos maternités ce
budget prévoit d'ailleurs en 2024 une
augmentation de 8 milliards d'euros des
dépenses d'assurance maladie c'est 54
milliards d'euros comparés à il y a 5
ans c'était 10 milliards sous le dernier
gouvernement de gauche 20 milliards sous
le dernier de droite on est donc bien
loin de l'austérité proclamée par nos
oppositions en commission de nombreux
amendements ont été adoptés nous avons
porté avec la majorité des amendements
qui renforce la prévention avec le
dépistage systématique du site
omégalovirus pour les femmes enceintes
qui améliore la prise en charge des
patients avec la transformation du
financement de la dialyse et de la
radiothérapie mais aussi beaucoup
d'autres dont des mesures
d'accompagnement pour les prochesdents
aussi madame la ministre j'aimerais
avoir votre avis sur et vos intentions
sur ces sujets je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Madame AG
le ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
profession de
santé les députés madame la députée
Stéphanie Rist vousz souligné dans
quelques minutes va débuter l'examen du
PLFSS je vous rejoins c'est un texte
engagé et responsable je vous remercie
aussi d'avoir souligné la réalité des
chiffres et du budget de la Sécurité
sociale 643 milliards d'euros vous
l'avez dit don près de 255 milliards
d'euros pour l'ONDAM 2024 et vous l'avez
répété depuis 2017 c'est bien 54
milliards d'euros supplémentaires qui
ont été consacrés à la santé contre 10
milliards sur le mandat précédent c'est
inédit et cela se trad traduit
l'engagement sans faille du gouvernement
pour investir dans notre système de
santé notre ambition les double assurer
la pérennité de notre modèle social pour
protéger les Français poursuivre la
transformation nécessaire de notre
système de santé pour mieux répondre aux
défis qui sont devant nous et s'engager
et prendre ce vrai virage pour la
prévention le gouvernement partage
pleinement les propositions que vous
portez c'était l'esprit des comptes de
Ségure et de la coconstruction que nous
en contons pter en particulier sur les
deux pistes que vous avez évoqué sur le
dépistage du
citomégalovirus vous pouvez compter sur
notre soutien et sur le déploiement de
ce dépistage avec un avis de la hasas
nous partageons pleinement cette
ambition qui s'inscrit dans le virage
préventif et que nous souhaitons porter
sur la dialyse et la radiothérapie nous
souhaitons avancer avec vous sur ce
sujet c'est un travail qu'il nous faudra
mener de façon concertée avec tous les
acteurs en privilégiant avant tout la
qualité des parcours des patients
concernant les prédents vous savez que
Aurore Berger a présenté il y a quelques
temps une stratégie nationale et dents
et que sur ce sujet nous avons déjà
beaucoup fait et qu'il nous reste encore
à faire et à construire ensemble vous le
voyez madame la rapporteur générale le
gouvernement est pleinement ouvert au
débat parlementaires sur ce texte
essentiel pour notre pays merci Madame
la Ministre la parole est à Monsieur fré
Cabrier madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur ce
samedi des incidents graves se sont
produits dans le Tarne lors de la
manifestation contre l'autoroute a69
castre Toulouse plusieurs centaines d'
d'individus radicaux cagoulés et casqués
ne se sont pas contentés de dégrader
deux reprises deux entreprises du BTP
avec des camions br
ils s'en sont pris également au sapeur
Pompi qui intervenait sur le lieu des
incendies à un vigile d'une des deux
entreprises de BTP et aux forces de
l'ordre avec des mortiers et des pierres
j'en profite pour saluer le travail des
policiers et des gendarmes présents sur
le site et apporter notre soutien au six
gendarmes et policiers blessés ainsi
qu'au responsables et salariés des
entreprises prises pour possible des
dispositifs de contrôle aux abords de la
manifestation avai heureusement permis
aux forces de l'ordre de saisir des
armes par destination barre de fer
pioche boule de pétanque couteau masque
à gaz évitant certainement des faits
encore plus graves à noter que seulement
9 personnes ont été interpellé sur les
2000 activistes violents présents lors
de cette manifestation selon les
chiffres de la préfecture d'autre
part d'autre part des députés nin de
leur écharpe tricolore était présent
comme souvent dans ce type de
manifestation violente cautionnant ainsi
ces actes par leur présence les députés
présents sur place seul monsieur le
député a la parole s'il vous plaît les
députés présents sur place ont min
minimisé ces violences affirmant que la
manifestation avait été pacifiste tout
en refusant de parler de violence mais
de dégradation pire une députée a
justifié l'incendie de camion dans une
cimenterie par le fait que la production
de ciment pollue beaucoup Monsieur le
Ministre on retrouve dans ces exactions
les mêmes groupes écoterrorist qui avait
SV à
saintineur le député la parole est à
Monsieur
Gérald ministre de l'Intérieur et des
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
outrers monsieur le ministre a la
parole Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs
les Députés monsieur le député après le
ministre en charge des transports je
veux moi aussi rendre en effet hommage
au policiers aux gendarmes au SAP
pompier et à Monsieur le Préfet du Tarne
qui a je crois très bien su répondre
effectivement soit aux manifestations
qui sont déroulé en dehors de leur
déclaration mais aussi lors des 5000
personnes manifestantes au 500 personnes
particulièrement violentes cela avait
été annoncé par le collectif des
soulèvements de la Terre vous en avez
fait référence 12 personnes ont été
Inter
qure camions ont été brûlés un bâtiment
lui-même a été incendié 20 drones
monsieur le ministre a la parole s'il
vous plaît 20 drones ont été utilisés
par ceux qui voulaient en effet
coordonner les actions de lancer de
Pierr de lancer de de cocktail contre
les contre les policiers et contre les
gendarmes et surtout un certain nombre
de personnes violant une centaine ont
été violé le droit de propriété pour
s'installer sans droit ni titre dans une
ferme celle de la Crémade où il voulait
installer je cite une Zade vous aurez
constater monsieur le député que nous
n'avons pas laissé installer une Zade
dans le territoire du Tarne que nous
avons sont des consignes extrêmement
claires pour les forces de l'ordre su
évacuer ces personnes alors qu'en effet
les policiers gendarmes ont subi
énormément de violence énormément de
violence lancer des des pavés sur
eux-mêmes effectivement dans des
conditions de grande difficultés pour un
maintien de l'ordre que l'on pourrait
qualifier de rural aujourd'hui 12
personnes ont été interpellées certaines
avec vous l'avez raison des armes des
armes importantes elles sont présentées
évidemment au service du ministre de la
Justice je veux dire par ailleurs s'il
vous plaît seul monsieur le ministre je
vais vous dire par ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
que le travail du ministère de
l'intérieur n'est pas de juger de la
qualité de tel ou tel projet
d'infrastructure mais d'appliquer les
décisions de justice lorsqu'elles ont
été rendues et c'est grâce d'ailleurs à
l'autorité des magistrats que
l'opération a été mis en place nous
devrions respecter é intentiné le droit
me semble-t-il lorsqu'on est élu
lorsqu'on est parlementaire et je veux
redire ici aucune Zade ne sera
constituée tant que je serai ministre de
l'Intérieur le ministre la parole est à
Madame
Valentin merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre lors des auditions
à la commission des affaires sociales le
discours était parfait mais entre le
discours et les les réalités des faits
le fossé é tabissal les départements
monsieur le ministre sont appelés à
voter leur le programme régional de
santé afin de soi-disant mieux
appréhender les enjeux du
vieillissement d'anticiper la dépendance
et de mieux prendre en charge le
handicap or ces PRS ont été rédigés sans
aucune concertation avec les
départements pourtant premier acteur
dans le domaine des solidarités résultat
c'est un fabuleux exercice
technocratique totalement déconnecté des
besoins des territoires du parcours de
soins des patients des attentes des
professionnels de santé et surtout sans
aucune vision à moyen long terme
monsieur le ministre je voudrais savoir
ce que nous allons faire des enfants en
situation de handicap sur les listes
d'attentes de ces jeunes adultes
maintenu en établissement enfants en
attente de place dans le secteur adulte
de toutes les orientations hors
département des enfants accueillis au
foyer de l'enfance faute de place en
pédopsychiatrie tant de questions sans
réponse qui témoignent de l'urgence et
du manque criant d'anticipation et de
moyens mais aussi du manque de
considération de ce gouvernement
totalement hors sol alors on aurait pu
penser que le PLFSS 2024 allait donner
une lueur d'espoir il n'en est rien la
5è branche n'étant pas suffisamment
financée et ce n'est pas trois
mesurettes qui vont sauver notre système
de santé monsieur le ministre 50 % des
hôpitaux sont déficitaires 70 % des
épades le président de la f la FHF
considère qu'il manque 2 milliards en
2023 et 2 milliards en 2024 les
pharmacies en milieu rural ferment leurs
portes les infirmiers les kinés tentent
comme ils le peuvent d'assurer le
maintien à domicile asphixié par les
charges et une nomenclature qui n'a pas
été revue depuis 2009 monsieur le
ministre vous l'avez reconnu leur
désolution l'argent n'est pas fléché au
bon endroit trop d'administratif pas
assez de soignant mais que fait-on je
n'ose même pas vous demander votre
vision à moyen et long terme tant les
discours ne restent que des
paroles la parole est à Madame Aurore
berger ministre des Solidarités et des
[Applaudissements]
familles merci madameés Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les les députés
madame la députée Valentin peut-être
deux réponses une première réponse sur
la question des adultes en situation de
handicap et donc en corollaire la
question des enfants et évidemment la
question de l'autonomie sur le premier
sujet on a aujourd'hui 10000 personnes
10000 adultes en situation de handicap
qui sont dans ce qu'on appelle les
amendements cretons c'est-à-dire qu'il
restent aujourd'hui dans des
établissements qui sont dédiés à nos
enfants c'est la raison pour laquelle on
a et s financé évidemment dans le PLFSS
le président de la République a au
Conseil national du handicap annoncer
les 50000 nouvelles solutions les 50000
nouvelles solutions l'idée est de les
flécher en priorité sur la création de
nouvelles place dans les établissements
médicaux sociaux et médicaux éducatifs
d'abord d'abord en direction des adultes
en situation de handicap je crois qu'il
n'y a pas un seul député dans cet
hémicycle qui n'a pas dans sa permanence
été contacté par des parents par des
familles d'enfants en situation de
handicap aujourd'hui devenus adultes qui
n'ont pas le bon niveau de solution donc
notre première responsabilité c'est
d'abord la création de ces places pour
les les adultes en situation de handicap
de manière à en finir avec ces
amendements cretons et faire en sorte
que chacun soit considéré avec dignité
et soit donc à la juste et à la bonne
place la deuxième chose c'est évidemment
sur la question de l'autonomie la la
question de l'autonomie c'est encore une
fois en 2024 40 milliards d'euros en
financement pour atteindre en 2027 45
milliards d'euros donc il y a évidemment
un choix un arbitrage qui a été rendu
qui est très clair qui est de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse adapter notre société
au vieillissement adapter notre société
au vieillissement c'est accepter que de
toute façon en 2030 il y aura plus de
Français qui seront plus âgés que 65 ans
pour la première fois il y aura plus de
personnes âgées plus de 65 ans par
rapport au moins de 15 ans c'est un
basculement démographique majeur auquel
l'ensemble évidemment de la société doit
pouvoir s'adapter d'où une montée en
charge budgétaire extrêmement puissante
et la reprise évidemment de la
proposition de loi bien vieillir qui a
été largement enrichie par le
parlementaires un amendement sur 5 a été
adopté rendez-vous à partir du 20
novembre pour continuer à enrichir ce
texte je vous remerci merci Madame la
min minist la parole est à Monsieur
Richard
[Applaudissements]
Ramos madame la Présidente ma question
fait maison s'adresse à Madame la
Ministre Olivia Grégoire madame la
ministre parfois il y a des sujets où
notre personne habite notre fonction de
façon plus prignante je vous sais madame
la ministre gastronome gastronome au
sens du partage de la table qui est ce
lieu d'échange parfois en France avec de
hâpres discussions mais aussi par fois à
Noël avec des douces réconciliations
nous avons en partage madame la ministre
l'amour d'une bonne blanquette ou d'un
bourguignon longuement mijoté quel que
soit notre pays notre culture manger
c'est raconter une histoire avec un
grand hache manger ce n'est pas mettre
des calories entre la lèvre supérieure
et la lèvre inférieure c'est raconter
une géographie des tours de mains
ancestraux et présents manger c'est bien
évidemment grand chef mais aussi les
175000 restaurants et bistr français où
on mange avec ses collègues sa famille
c'est un repas au restaurant de
communion un mariage ce sont des moments
privilégiés qui rythment notre vie et
celle de nos proches mais il y a dans le
mot restaurant aussi le mot cuisiner
nous cherchons le mot cuisinier apparu
au 13e siècle qui a été défini en 1835
par l'Académie française il s'agit de
faire de la nourriture de transformer
des produits brute quand nous
recherchons un restaurant souvent nous
recherchons en fait un cuisinier ou une
cuisinière c'est-à-dire une signature
personnelle dans l'assiette et cela
quelle que soit la sophistication du
plat nous avons tous mangé une mauvaise
salade césar avec une mauvaise
vinaigrette industrielle nous devons
combattre l'idée qu'un restaurant doit
être modélisé par des goûts
industrialisés car modéliser les goûts
c'est modiser les pensées et per tous la
même chose madame la ministre merci pour
ce combat courageux que vous venez pour
faire en sorte que nos restaurants de ne
viennent des vrais lieux de cuisine
aujourd'hui et demain monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame Olivia
Grégoire ministre délégué chargé des
petites et moyennes entreprises du
commerce de l'artisanat et du
[Musique]
tourisme madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Ramos nous sommes nombreux sur ces bancs
à connaître et à saluer l'engagement qui
est le vote depuis des années en faveur
du mieux manger du bien manger
effectivement nous avons en commun la
gastronomie mais aussi l'amitié et
Monsieur Paul évidemment bocus le disait
si bien il n'y a pas de bonne cuisine si
au départ elle n'est pas faite par
amitié pour celui ou celle à qui elle
est destinée et entre amis on ne triche
pas la gastronomie c'est l'art de
transformer des produits bruts sur place
pour créer des émotions on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui dans notre pays à quelques
mois des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques alors même que le monde
entier va venir en France découvrir nos
goûts nos produits bruts on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui ne pas mieux informer nos
consommateurs sur la réalité de ce qu'il
mangent au restaurant parce qu'entre
amis restaurateur et consommateur on ne
doit pas tricher nous avons donc écouté
le terrain pendant des mois ce qui
cuisinent merci d'avoir rappelé
l'étymologie du terme ceux qui sont nos
restaurateurs et qui transforment nos
produits bruts et à force d'écouter nous
avons entendu et je veux remercier le
soutien du président Guillaume casbarian
mais aussi celui de Bruno Le Maire la
mesure est simple et pleine de bon sens
obliger les restaurateurs à indiquer sur
les menus les plats qui ne sont pas
préparés sur place c'est une mesure de
bon sens pour nos producteurs pour nos
restaurateurs pour nos consommateurs
désormais au du label fait maison
désormais un Astérix une étoile peu
importe une mention claire et
obligatoire devra être spécifié afin que
le consommateur sache si le produit a
été fabriqué maison ou pas
entre amis on ne se juge pas je n'ai pas
non plus de jugement de valeur sur les
produits industriels on peut aussi
acheter un pâté ou une pte feuilleté
chez un artisan et le servir en le
madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur David
topiaak merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre alors que nous commençons
aujourd'hui en séance l'examen du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2024 les engag les
engagements pris dans le précédent n'ont
pas tous encore été respectés en
engageant déjà votre responsabilité via
un 493 vous aviez néanmoins fait le
choix volontaire de retenir une demande
de rapport déposée par notre
groupe celui-ci devait s'attacher à
identifier les professionnels du soin du
médico-social et du social qui
n'auraient pas bénéficié des mesures de
revalorisation pris dans le cadre du
séure de la santé et des accords la
Fourcade très attendu par ses personnels
il devait être remis au Parlement fin
juin or il en a été
rien je n'ai pas à vous Rapp ici combien
3 ans après ces accords il existe encore
de nombreuses inégalités dans les
structures entre les personnels sans que
l'on puisse avoir une vision claire de
la situation j inclus les écoutants de5
dont la prime promise l'année dernière
n'a pas non plus été versé il y a
urgence nous parlons de personnel avec
des salaires déjà peu élevés proches du
SMIC qui subissent de plein fouet la
crise inflationniste qui continue de
s'appauvrir considérant le le vert à
moitié plein vous affirmez que ce sont
près de 700000 salariés dont 500000
environ au titre du Ségure et des
accords la Fourcade qui ont été
revalorisés certes nous nous nous en
félicitons mais combien en sont encore
exclus nous avons tous sur nos
circonscriptions suffisamment d'exemples
pour juger que ce rapport amènerait une
clarification
bienvenue alors que nos débat devrait
vraisemblablement être interrompu très
prochainement par un nouvel usage du 493
je regr par avance que nous ne puissions
toujours pas échanger sur les
amendements que le groupe lot a déposé
permettant d'évoquer le profin des
enrois du secteur médico-social merci
madame la Première ministre les
engagements pr de monieur le député la
parole est à Madame Aurore berger
ministre des Solidarités et des
familles merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député déjà j'ai appris que
vous n'aviez pas encore reçu le rapport
qui qui devait vous être remis et donc
j'ai interrogé les services pour qu'il
vous soi remis avant la fin du mois
comme c'était évidemment nécessaire que
ce soit le cas de manière à ce que
l'ensemble des délais à l'avenir soit
tenu parce que c'est évidemment ce que
le gouvernement doit au parlementaires
donc ça c'est le premier point deuxième
point sur la question de la
revalorisation et du Ségure et de ce
qu'on a malheureusement communément
appelé les les oubliés du Ségur on a ce
que je disais précédemment 900000
personnels qui ont été revalorisés dans
les établissements médicaux-sociaux ça
veut dire l' intégralité des personnels
des éepad et tous les personnels
soignants et les personnels socio
éducatifs de l'ensemble des autres
établissements des emss donc ça veut
dire qu'on a un engagement sur 900000 de
ces professionnels qui ont été
revalorisés pour un engagement de l'état
de 3,5 milliards d'euros ce qui est
quand même évidemment très conséquent
mais je suis très vigilante surtout à ce
que sur toutes les nouvelles mesures on
ne recommette pas on va dire des erreurs
qui ont pu exister de manière à ce que
médico-social et sanitaire avance
conjointement cette c'est dans cet
esprit qu'on travaille avec Aurélien
Rousseau avec Agnès firmain lebudau avec
Fadila catabi c'est la raison pour
laquelle quand il y a eu des
revalorisations sur la question du
travail de nuit du travail le weekend
notamment dans les hôpitaux la même
mesure va s'appliquer aux épades public
c'est la raison aussi pour laquelle je
vous annonce aujourd'hui que sur le
privé non lucratif cette mesure leur
sera bien étendue pour qu'il y ait
encore une fois la même symétrie entre
les établissements sanitaires et les
établissements médicau-sociaux donc dans
le PLFSS 2024 que vous les avez à
examiner à partir de aujourd'hui ce sera
bien ces engagements qui seront tenus on
marche sur deux jambes le sanitaire et
le médico-social il y en a pas une qui
prévaut sur l'autre parce qu'en vérité
elles sont évidemment conjointes de la
manière avec laquelle on doit pouvoir
reconnaître et revaloriser l'ensemble
des professionnels du soin je vous
remercie merci Madame la Ministre la
parole est à Madame Julie
larnoes ma question s'adresse à Madame
Sarah elerie secrétaire d'État chargé de
la biodiversité madame la ministre
aujourd'hui le constat est sans appel la
biodiversité est en chute libre un
constat que des milliers de
scientifiques ont établi et qui
provoquent de graves effets sur nos
conditions de vie sur terre et qu'est-ce
que vous proposer pour faire face à
cette 6e extinction de masse un loto
êtes-vous sérieuse lever 6 millions
d'euros alors qu'il en faudrait 600
millions pour être à la hauteur du défi
vous prétendez pouvoir limiter l'érosion
de la biodiversité grâce à un jeu de
hasard mais en réalité cette sinistre
initiative ne sert que la logique
libérale de la Française des jeux
renforce les pratiques addictives des
plus fragiles et entretient de manière
peu éthique la confusion entre jeux
d'argent et financement d'action
d'intérêt général c'est absolument
irresponsable et inconscient derrière
cette opération de communication vous ne
masquez que votre incompétence crasse
sur le dos de la biodiversité
qu'avez-vous dit sur les projets
climaticides l'artificialisation de
milliers d'hectctares de zone humide et
boisé comme sur laa 69 vous êtes-vous
jointte au cri d'alarme des
scientifiques et des écologistes non
vous vous êtes tu vous vous ê vous
êtes-vous indigné face à la prolongation
des pesticides et du glyphosate en
particulier keneni vous vous êtes tu
pourtant tout le monde le sait
l'artificialisation des sols et les
pesticides sont les premières causes de
perte de la biodiversité alors madame la
ministre la préservation de la
biodiversité se joue-elle au hasard ou
allez-vous enfin réellement et
sérieusement vous former aux enjeux de
biodiversité pour pouvoir prétendre
défendre la cause que vous êtes supposé
défendre je vous remercie merci madame
la députée la parole est à Madame Sarah
la secrétaire d'État chargée de la
biodiversité madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés madame la
députée soyons sérieux une minute le
budget le budget de la biodiversité le
budget de la préservation de la nature
n'a jamais été aussi important que sous
ce gouvernement il a été multiplié par 4
depuis votre départ du pouvoir et depuis
notre
arrivée le budget de la biodiversité
madame la députée le budget présenté
dans cette loi de finances c'est 1,2
milliard d'euros madame la députée
d'augmentation c'est deux fois les 600
millions dont vous parlez madame la
députée la préservation de la
biodiversité c'est la stratégie
nationale biodiversité que nous
travaillons avec les scientifiques avec
le monde associatif avec avec les élus
locaux c'est la stratégie qui reprend
les cinq pressions et qui met la baisse
sur les cinq pressions d'abord en
priorité ensuite la restauration de la
nature et enfin la mobilisation de tous
les Français madame la députée moi je ne
fais pas le tri entre les Français oui
j'aime l'idée que on mobilise à l'image
du l'OTO du patrimoine d'une certaine
manière les Français qui vont jouer pour
qu'il puisse flash codter et découvrir
20 projets 20 projets de tourbière 20
projets de JIDE 20 projets qui
permettent la préservation de la tortue
d'Erman des projets qui dans le fond
sont au plus proches de chez nous parce
que la biodiversité elle est aussi de
proximité alors madame la députée vous
voulez essayer de faire croire que le
budget est réduit à 6 million d'euros
c'est faux c'est 10 milliards d'euros
d'augmentation du ministère de
l'écologie rien que dans ce PLF 40
milliards d'euros de budget madame la
madame la députée la biodiversité
aujourd'hui c'est d'abord la
mobilisation de tous soyez du côté de
ceux qui ne jugent pas mais de ceux qui
réunissent les Français et vous avez
madame la députée l'opportunité de le
faire aujourd'hui avec aussi un jeu
populaire merci madame la
députée je vous propose madame la
ministre à l'UTO des ministres pour
participer réellement à une formation
sur les enjeux de biodiversité qui ne
sont pas réellement pris en compte dans
les politiques publiques et les projets
qui sont défendu par le gouvernement et
peut-être participer à une manifestation
des soulèvements de la terre pour
comprendre réellement les enjeux de
biodiversité que nous défendons la
parole est à Monsieur Sébastien pardon
madame la
ministre madame la députée ne soyez pas
insultante vous n'avez pas l'exclusivité
de l'écologie ou de l'engagement pour la
nature il se trouve il se trouve madame
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Sébastien
R
madame la Première ministre avec 13 493
vous avez démontré votre incapacité à
trouver une méthode démocratique qui
fasse République pourtant lors des deux
dernières législatures par deux fois
tous les parlementaires ont eu la force
de voter deux lois à l'unanimité ces
parlementaires dont certains siègent ici
encore ont mis en œuvre une idée héritée
de la 2e République la garantie d'emploi
contre le chômage les territoires zéro
chômeurs longue durée selon vos mots de
juin 2021 c'est une réussite oui c'est
une réussite en proposant des emplois en
CDI sur des secteurs non solvables par
le marché mais radicalement utile pour
l'écologie et le social ces entreprises
créées par les chômeurs eux-mêmes
transformment des déserts économiques en
oasis d'emploi ils permettent avant tout
de redonner fierté et sens au travail en
moyenne ces personnes sont privées
d'emploi depuis près de 5 ans souvent
des maires célibataires des personnes de
plus de 50 ans ou en situation de
handicap la vie ne les épargne pas elles
ont vécu vos lois plein emploi et
retraite comme autant de claques en
pleine tête les désignant comme des
citoyens de second rang à l'odève zone
rurale quartier prioritaire
centrre-ville sur les 80 première
embauche une seule personne avait une
voiture une seule aujourd'hui ce sont
plus de 100 50 personnes qui étaient
empêché de travailler qui ont un CDI que
dites-vous à la centaine aux milliers de
personnes en France qui attendent un
emploi dans leur commune à celles et
ceux qui vous écoutent ici au balcon ou
juste à l'extérieur de l'Assemblée
restez à la porte attendez vous serez
bientôt sanctionné madame la Première
ministre allez-vous respecter votre
parole et celle du président de la
République qui parle d'une clé dans la
lutte contre la pauvreté en ne retirant
pas un seul euro à cette expérimentation
ou
laisser de nombreuses personnes au bord
du chemin merci monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur
Olivier ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député vous avez
conclu votre question en disant
allez-vous retirer de l'argent à cette
expérimentation allez-vous je crois
reprendreos mots ne pas retirer un € à
l'expérimentation la réalité c'est que
nous faisons mieux en 2023 dans le
budget 2023 vous navez pas voté mais il
s'applique les fonds consacrés à
l'expérimentation territoire Z chôur ce
sont 44 millions d'euros dans le budget
pour 2024 69 million d'euros une
augmentation de 50 % parlez-moi de
baisse de budget après ça 50 %
d'augmentation toutes les structures
d'insertion par l'activité économique
aimerent avoir la même augmentation
quand bien même nous arrivons à 1
milliard et demi la deuxième chose que
je voulais vous dire c'est que nous
avons nous avons monsieur le député eu
des
contacts madame la présid ministre
paroci prés litess n'a toujours pas
gagné les bands de la France insoumise
madame monsieur le
député nous avons eu des contacts nous
avons des contacts avec l'associationil
vous plat l'association territoir zé
chôur vendredi mon cabinet a dit à
l'association que si le pilotage de
cette expérimentation était amélioré
nous pouvions trouver 10 millions
d'euros supplémentaires en 2024 ils ont
refusé 3ème chose il y a une évaluation
une évaluation sur les conditions de
mise en œuvre et une évaluation sur une
des conditions un des engagements pris
par l'association au niveau national qui
était créé de la valeur à hauteur de
6000 € par emploi en fonction de
l'expérimentation en fonction des
territoires habilités nous nous
continuerons à soutenir mais le budget
de l'État n'est pas sans fin on ne peut
pas décider d'un budget de l'État
uniquement par les demandes de ceux qui
peuvent en bénéficier il nous faut du
pilotage il nous faut de la
régulation merci la parole est à
Monsieur Jean
Terlier merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outrmes
concernant les violences de la
manifestation de ce weekend contre le
chantier autoroutier entre castre et
Toulouse et la tentative avortée
d'installation d'une Zade dans le sud du
Tarne je voudrais au préalab remercier
Clément B ministre des Transports
d'avoir rappelé que ce projet d'69 a été
déclaré d'intérêt national à la suite
d'un long parcours démocratique qui a
conduit la communauté d'agglomération
castre maamé le département du Tarne la
région Occitanie et plus de 1000 élus
Tarnis a plébiscité un projet afin de
désenclaver ce TER teritoire le sud du
Tarne et redonner de l'attractivité à ce
bassin d'emploi de 80000 personnes c'est
aujourd'hui 75 % des Sud Tarn qui
attendent la mise en service de cette
autoroute en 2025 rappelez que force
doit rester à l'état de droit et qu'en
l'espèce c'est la DUP de 2018 qui fond
la légitimité de ce chantier et non les
tergiversations d'une minorité de
soi-disant militant écologistes très
éloigné des préoccupations des Sud
Tarn vous remercier et à travers vous
les services de la pré duarne et les
1600 gendarmes et policiers déployés
ainsi que les sapeurs pompiers pour
assurer le déroulement de cette
manifestation déplorz enfin que malgré
les engagements des organisateurs de la
manifestation des violences Inui et des
exactions ont été commises par plus de
2500 pseudoécologistes radicalisé et
entraîné la dégradation et l'incendie de
deux entreprises starnaises causant de
nombreux blessés parmi les forces de
l'ordre sans la mise en place de votre
cellule antisade il est à craindre que
les exactions auraient été encore plus
nombreuses monsieur le ministre j'aurais
souhaité avoir votre sentiment sur la
nécessité d'avoir une réflexion sur la
responsabilité des organisateurs de
manifestations notamment lorsqu'il est
établi comme en l'espèce qu'ils ont eu
la volonté manifeste de s'affranchir du
parcours déclaré de la manifestation
d'une part qui se sont rendus complices
et à tout le moins de manière passive
des violences et exactions commises
d'autrre part et ce en présence de
députés de ce côté de l'hémicycle et
qu'ils ont enfin incité des manifestants
à implanter une Zade dans la plus
parfaite illégalité je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outr
[Applaudissements]
maires merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député j'observe comme vous
que les habitants du Tarne les élus quel
que soit leur bord politique en
responsabilité que ce soit la présidente
Delga d'ocitan qui pourtant ne partage
pas ne partage pas les opinions du
gouvernement que ce soit les élus
départementaux et les élus municipaux
tous soutiennent en effet ce projet
d'infrastructure reconnu d'utilité
publique et qu'il est parfois plus
facile quand on est élu parisien d'avoir
un avis sur comment on doit se déplacer
dans le
Tarne en ce qui concerne le ce projet
d'infrastructure de de transport je
laisserai évidemment le ministre des
transport évoqué à la fois son utilité
et bien sûr sa sa confirmation je me
concentrerai sur la de l'ordre public
puisque les policiers les gendarmes les
préfets ne font qu'appliquer les règles
de la loi que vous votez Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires et les
décisions de justice nombreuses et
répétées puisque les policiers les
gendarmes eux appliquent les décisions
de justice et dans le cas extrêmement
précis le la préfecture du tar que je
voudrais ici remercier a discuté avec
des organisateurs une partie d'entre eux
n'ont pas respecté en effet ce qui avait
été évoqué notamment le cheminement des
manifestations et des cortèges mettant
en danger les manifestants même des
contrôles fait très en amont montré que
de très nombreuses armes ont été saisies
par plus de 5000 opérations de contrôle
et c'est rare d'arriver dans une
manifestation avec des pavés des
cocktails molotophe des couteaux des
silles des marteaux et utiliser en effet
20 drones 20 drones qui ont été utilisés
et brouillés par les services pour voir
comment travailler en effet les forces
de l'ordre donc oui les 12 interpellés
sont présentés devant les services de
monsieur le garde des saau je rappelle
que c'est une autorité judiciaire qui a
organiser évidemment cette
interpellation oui en effet nous allons
garder le site notamment de la Crémade
et nous allons voir comment on peut
mettre en responsabilité une partie des
organisateurs pour ne pas avoir tenu en
effet les engagements qu'ils ont pu
tenir et puis je constate que les
soulouslevants de la terre sont à
initiative ce sujet le Conseil d'État
rendra bientôt une décision au fond
j'espère qu'il suivra le
gouvernement la parole est à Monsieur
Yanni mon merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur le
ministre dans dans notre pays nous ne
prenons pas soin de celles et ceux qui
prennent soin de nous les Sapur pompiers
sont exposés lors de leurs interventions
à de nombreuses substances toxiques
c'est ce qui a conduit le Centre
international de recherche sur le cancer
à classer en 2022 l'exposition
professionnelle des pompiers comme
cancérogène en France dès 2003 un
rapport commandé par l'un de vos
prédécesseurs concluait la nécessité de
recueillir des données fiables
exhaustives sur les maladies
professionnel des sapeurs pompiers et de
mettre sur pied une veille sanitaire sur
la question c'était il y a 20 ans de
puis aucune démarche n'a réellement été
engagée en ce sens cela malgré de
nouvelles études alarmantes constatant
des cancers plus fréquents chez les
sapeurs pompiers que dans le reste de la
population et malgré l'alerte de l'an
qui rappel en 2019 l'urgence d'engager
une surveillance épidémiologique y
compris pour les pompiers actuellement à
la retraite en Australie 12 types de
cancer au Canada 19 types de cancer aux
États-Unis 28 types de cancers sont
reconnu maladie professionnelle chez les
pompiers en France un seul le carcinome
du nasopharinx
et nous n'avons aucune donnée sur le
nombre actuel de pompiers atteints de
cancer les inquiétudes grandissent
concernant l'impact des retardateurs de
flammes c'estes composés chimiques
présents dans les meubles les mousses de
matelas les jouets ou les voitures ce
sont des perturbateurs endocriniens
reconnus dont la dangerosité est
aujourd'hui avéré nos sapeurs pompiers
ils sont particulièrement exposés et pas
uniquement par les voies respiratoires
mais aussi par le contact avec la peau
par dépôt de particules et malgré les
équipements actuels monsieur le ministre
depuis 2003 nous avons perdu beaucoup
trop de temps comptez-vous en instaurer
un véritable suivi médical une
investigation par la récolte de données
de la prévention et engager les études
épidémiologiques et biologique
indispensable pour notamment élargir la
liste des cancers reconnus comme maladie
professionnelle chez nos saport pompiers
très bien bien merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des autres
maires merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député oui je suis prêt à
élargir cette liste en effet vous avez
parfaitement raison les SAP bonpiers
professionnels et volontaires
contrairement à d'autres pays n'ont pas
les mêmes suivis épidémiologiques en
France et il est évident que leur
intervention dans des cadres de plus en
plus dangereux avec une toxicité de
produits que nous trouvons de plus en
plus chez nos concitoyens les poussent
sans doute vous avez raison à contracter
des maladies extrêmement graves et
notamment des cancers alors voilà 2 ans
que que j'ai lancé en effet les travaux
qui auraient dû être lancés bien
auparavant ne serait-ce que notamment
que la médecine de prévention à
intérieur du fonctionnement des dis
puisse faire que les sapurs pompiers
puissent tous les 2 ans au moins avoir
une consultation médicale ce qui était
pas le cas jusqu'à présent mais vous
avez parfaitement raison nous sommes en
retard sur les données et il y a plus de
6 mois j'ai lancé avec mon collègue de
la santé une étude épidémiologique qui
mettra malheureusement encore un petit
peu de temps et utilisé par le knam et
avec linerme pour savoir exactement ce
qui se passe pour dans la vie
professionnelle des Sapur pompiers des
Sapur pompiers volontaes pour en tirer
toutes les conclusions de suivi
évidemment d'accompagnement
professionnel et je pense que ce sera le
travail à faire avec les 10 avec les
syndicats des Sapur pompiers
professionnels avec la Fédération des
SAP pompiers mais également bien sûr
avec la Direction générale de la
sécurité civile qui au ministère de
l'Intérieur et bien évidemment permettre
à ceux qui sont touchés par ces maladies
extrêmement graves de récupérer
dédommagement lorsque c'est possible et
bien sûr un accompagnement professionnel
pour changer de métier ou pour pouvoir
effectivement être accompagné dans des
situations beaucoup plus dramatiques
donc je je m'engage monsieur le député
lorsque ces résultats sont connus de
revenir vers vous et bien sûr d'apporter
à à nos saort pompiers tout
l'accompagnement que un grand pays comme
la France doit avoir merci Monsieur le
Ministre la séance des questions au
Gouvernement est terminée la séance est
suspendu pour 10 minutes et elle
reprendra avec le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour